Ladies and gentlemen.
Bam.
We are live with my pal,
Brian,
Callan,
ladies and gentlemen.
Right.
Carolyn,
good to be here.
An honor to be here at pleasure and the honor to have you sir and client is uh,
my longest running front and Hollywood.
I think so,
right?
Yeah,
for sure.
Years.
Yeah.
We've been friends a long ass time.
Almost 20 years.
Yeah.
94 or something like that.
People still come to me.
It was 98,
1995 and people still come up to me and asked me if we're half brothers.
You are the ones that abuse to say it on Wikipedia.
That's right.
I MDB one of those.
It's a rumor.
I like keeping it alive.
Keep it alive.
I'm,
I never refuted.
Yeah,
either do I now.
Now I think you were the one who told me about Gracie Jujitsu.
Yeah,
I remember that.
I remember we connected immediately.
A totally,
you show up at those guys are all just low blood sugar.
Just a bunch of actors.
All of a sudden this guy,
see,
I'm like,
wait a minute.
That guy looks like me,
but he's thicker and you look way more extreme and yet a 10 time horizon you
really can possibly muster.
I was like,
that guy looks like he fights and you're like,
yeah,
I fight.
I like to fight,
I need to fight.
I didn't think I need to be in class otherwise I'll end up in jail.
And I was like,
that guy's going to be my friend for ever.
We connected so quick right away with everything,
every retarded thing.
We'd love pit bulls and,
and we're,
we both know it's retarded.
That's the difference.
All of my extreme macho psycho shit,
I know it's fucked up.
Like I know my tattoos are fucked up.
I know my neck is too big.
I don't give a fuck,
you know?
I know my car is too loud.
I don't care whether you like it.
You've always been my canary in the coal mine.
You as well.
You know,
as long as I know you're still out there alive,
someone's rocking at the right way.
No doubt.
I remember that time we spent literally a whole day.
We were looking for pitfalls.
For me.
We have to find,
I was like,
I want to jaws on a leash.
I just want a life support system for jars.
You're like,
all right,
me too.
And so we,
we ended up looking at,
I saw this one that it said there's no bull in our pits and we get there and
this guy clearly fought his past.
Oh yeah,
that guy.
Do you know where that guy,
you'll have more than I thought when I,
when I,
when have a dog killed the goats,
killed goats.
It attacked the baby cow.
By the time they will shoot it to death it.
Meanwhile it was this 35 pound little dog.
That's what people don't know about pit bulls.
The really crazy ones aren't like the big muscle ones.
The really crazy ones or the little ones because they can pick them up and move
around easier and fight.
This thing will look like a big,
they're bred,
they're not bred for like the bread,
the fighting weight classes,
the baddest motherfuckers on these little 35 pounders and that's what he had.
The dog did not look like a pit bull.
Like,
if you think of a pit bull,
you think of this like crazy muscular.
Yeah.
Concoction of science and breeding like a fleshlight of,
that's right.
We're going to talk about this before we get going.
We are sponsored by the flashlight.
This is,
we have a sponsor for our podcast and if we don't get,
we were supposed to talk about in the beginning of the show,
if you've never used one of the things,
these things I highly recommended.
I know you are a fellow pervert your feel that I sure haven't.
I have not fucked up.
You have at a reseller.
That's the butthole version.
The Bud Oh version.
And Dude,
it's way better than beating off.
I mean it's,
it's a fucking incredible invention.
Yeah.
Well,
I've seen these used in poor,
not that I ever watched should be something that every man has for real.
Because look,
if you,
if you masturbate and you do,
okay,
everyone does.
Yeah.
Come on.
You don't have 50 bucks laying around to,
to give yourself some pleasure.
There's a lot of girls who you won't call after you fucked up.
I'm going to be honest with you,
I'm sticking my finger in this.
And it's true.
It's true.
This feels really good.
It feels awesome,
dude.
There's a lot of girls,
there's a lot of girls that you would not,
especially when you're young and dumb and you know,
you're just,
your Dick is totally leading your life.
That shit could save your career.
That's shit could push you in a positive direction.
They've gay ones where it's a little butts.
So instead of like the cheeks,
that's like a little butt cheeks.
Have you seen that?
Yeah.
Where k one flashlight.com or get a judgment and say you go to my website,
you click on the link,
there's like a 15% discount again.
So you have to talk about that in the beginning.
But you know what,
I would talk about it anyway just if I didn't know and then I found out.
People need to know.
Yeah,
I'm surprised at the things are more popular.
Fantastic.
But yeah,
these are a little pit bulls back to,
uh,
our,
our story.
I mean,
you had,
you had the craziest little guy.
He was awesome.
You had squigy I remember it wasn't a squeaky Fromme squeeze group killed my
dog.
She came,
she was a coffee table.
I've never seen a dog that she looked like an allergen.
And the reason why I got this fucking dog,
this dog was a prison dog,
right?
This dog was in the,
like literally in the,
the,
the La is in the POW.
I go loyalty from the pound and was there for awhile.
Nobody wanted this dog.
It's crazy.
Little muscular pit bull.
And a Brian calls me with his ex girlfriend who's also fucking crazy.
Patty Jenkins,
who is the director of that movie monster.
One of the coolest checks ever.
She's nuts too.
Okay.
So that both nuts and they're both talking about this pit bull that I have to
rescue.
So they call me up and tell me I have to rescue this.
And I'm like,
fuck.
So I already have two dogs,
right?
And I make the cardinal sin of bringing a female home to another female.
You cannot do now with pit bulls anyway.
No,
no.
You can't do with any dogs.
Apparently.
I want you to do a pound to get a pimple.
I seems like even because his friend,
his friend Brian,
Karen took one look at the dog away.
I said to Patty Ego,
if Joe sees this dog,
he's going to adopt that.
He cannot resist.
Here's a problem.
I'm a retard.
Okay,
and he's a retard as well,
and all retards need is another retard to agree with them and then they'll just
do something totally normal.
That's how Vegas was started and talent.
He just heard that,
right.
I'll buy it.
So just because it was already in his head like I was so susceptible.
It's like,
yeah,
really what she looked like.
She's like,
she's kind of fucking giant head and she's sold so solid genius.
I said,
you should look for off the corrugator.
She looks like an alligator with pitbull.
Meanwhile,
she was the sweetest dog ever,
but she hated other dogs,
hated them.
They're unforgiving,
unforgiving,
and ruthless.
She was willing to fight for the death,
to fight to the death for your attention to fee.
I had a female police dog,
German shepherd,
and a pit bull,
and they used to get in such bad vitamin for me.
I was just looking at $1,600 there and other $1,600 there is.
They're tearing each other up for the vet.
I got so good though.
It choking them not just right on cod.
Problem is not when you're there,
their problems when you're not.
Exactly.
And that's what happened with squeaking.
Yeah.
She killed one of my dogs when I here.
Yeah,
she's a crazy dog.
But she just did,
would not tolerate any bullshit.
And because of the way they raise them,
man,
you know,
they,
they're just willing to fight to the death.
The game ones are the ones that get to s every other animal fights out of fear
or dominance and,
and dominance,
including territorial,
you know,
which,
which is under the umbrella of being territorial.
Whereas a pit bulls actually are bread to actually enjoy the fight in a lot of
times in a fight crime,
we're into it.
They're wagging their tail.
You know,
they're great dogs.
If you,
if you raise them and you,
you know,
you're there with them all the time.
They're super loving and really loyal companions,
but they're dangerous as fuck when it comes to other animals.
There's no doubt who crazy.
Yeah.
[inaudible] having them.
I prefer to not have them even though,
you know,
I loved my dogs.
They were awesome dogs.
They were super friendly and obedient and they were really like affectionate too
much man.
Too crazy.
It's crazy.
It's really dangerous.
You know,
people's other people's dogs get fucked up by your dog and you feel like a
Douche bag.
You know?
It's like you can't take them to the dog park if they're on a lease.
Might my dog bit at someone's face.
Some someone's dog's face through the fence and grabbed a hold of it through
this dog fence.
We were walking.
I totally didn't expect it.
We were walking and he's on the leash and this dog sticks his head through the
fence and he's like,
what?
Pitch Guy?
He's locked onto it so quick.
He had half of the fence in his teeth and half of his dogs phase.
You have to choke them off.
Yeah,
I had a pole.
You have to grab his collar and twist it.
Yeah.
In the,
I had to put them to sleep.
I had to put them asleep a couple times.
I got to put them asleep when he was trying to kill my cat.
Yeah,
he was fucking nuts.
It was a great,
yeah,
thanks.
Fracture.
He was a great dog like with people,
but with animals and it was not how I raised them.
It just is.
It's just their genetics.
Yeah.
You know,
I raised him around his car.
I raised them around cats and the more we let was around him all the time.
It just,
they're just too crazy.
But the more we learn about genetics anyway,
the more I realize it's so much.
It's a lot less nurture than it is nature.
We are slaves to our DNA and a lot of ways there's a lot of that going on for
sure.
In both humans and in animals.
There's nothing you could do.
I mean there's,
it's all moving in a certain direction for a reason.
Okay.
Cause this is the best way that the species stay strong,
you know?
And there's a bunch of fucking chemicals and a lot of them are dictating your
actions all the time.
And if you're a pit bull,
I mean,
how much of,
no,
no.
It's going to get in your head.
Very good.
Now the reason this book we were talking about yesterday where,
you know,
genetically for thousands of years people have learned how to cross breed,
and,
and whether it's plants or animals and come up with what they want.
But now with genetic engineering,
we're going to have crazy abilities on pinpoint accuracy,
like combining and actual like alligator with,
you know,
I mean for real,
like,
yeah,
I get it with a lion.
I mean they're,
they're doing crazy experiments where they can cross pollinate.
Yeah.
DNA.
That's totally inside the realm of possibility.
Yeah.
You know,
it's really nuts,
man.
His dogs,
no one real,
there's no real answer to how people bred dogs to be so crazy different.
And they all came from malls.
Genetically.
All dogs come from walls.
And that was like a big shock when they found that out because they're just
leaves a whole lot of questions like,
you know,
we don't,
haven't,
they don't know.
They don't know where the delineation happened and how they all know.
They thought it was a bunch of other wild candidates.
And I would have to double check this article because I don't really recall the
details of it,
but I remember that they were shocked that they found that dog's DNA was a
direct from wolves and that somehow or another,
a wolf became a Chihuahua.
You know,
a wool became a bulldog.
they just slowly,
bro,
how the fuck did that happen?
Well,
that,
that's,
that's breeding.
That's thousands of years of breeding.
Seems wrong.
They can do that.
Supports it.
I know,
I know.
It's right.
But it seems wrong.
It seems like if you had to bet,
you know,
you'd be like,
how could that be?
Right.
How's that possible?
A fucking Chihuahua.
It came from a wolf,
right?
That there's no way could you make something that human beings as you,
as they learn more about the genome,
like they couldn't figure out why,
um,
aids never became a heterosexual disease in this country,
but it was rampant in Africa.
Well,
what they just discovered was that when you have a certain mutation on your
gene,
that mutation,
if you're northern European,
anybody really the,
you know,
that's white,
uh,
or from of European descent,
they are the ones that survive the bubonic plague and everybody else died.
And the people that survived that plague had a certain mutation in their gene
that also makes them,
uh,
HIV resistant.
Whereas the bubonic plague did not hit Africa.
Africa had its own diseases,
but that particular plague never hit Africa.
So they never even,
they never developed a mutation in the gene to survive a plague like that.
It's kind of crazy.
It's fucking nuts.
I'm smart.
Just,
just the diversity of it all.
It's just how different things are happening all the time.
There's different diseases were fighting off and there's different things we're
adapting to and who knows what's going on with our brains right now.
Because of the different kinds of access to information that we have now with
the Internet and you know,
just with social networking,
like there's so much more access to information right now.
Like what,
who knows what's changing in our minds because of that.
Well,
what about the fact that when this,
when we create a,
an actual neural web where we have,
where everybody's genuinely connected to one specific club with something in
your body.
Yeah.
So possible we'll get there all talking about this already.
Well there already are.
They're already working on synthetic biology DNA that's synthetic that actually
can grow in a petri dish.
You know what,
you're listening to science talk with Brian Calendar.
Joe Rogan.
And did you ever think when you were doing that that you were in the hangover?
Did you ever think that movie was going to be like movie of the year,
the movie or the lie?
No idea.
That's,
I remember showing up there and I went in for the audition for Todd Phillips,
who have known for a while,
and I,
and I was planning on like a New York guy,
you know,
hey,
how you doing?
I'm,
this is,
you know,
Eddie.
And I was,
he likes when I improvised.
So I was kind of improvising and I put a girl there and when I got to the,
uh,
reading,
I said,
you know,
maybe I'll play.
I'm like,
you know,
I'm from Lebanon,
the ability,
if I make a Bagel prize,
ha ha,
laugh.
So I show up,
I do my two days of work,
uh,
in Vegas,
but Bradley Cooper,
I've known for eight years.
I've known Zack for 15.
I've just done a movie with Ed Helms before that.
And I'm talking to these guys,
name dropper.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
Named opera.
And,
but I remember saying,
we're talking to Bradley.
I was like,
how's it going?
He goes out,
I'll do it.
I've done a bunch of movies.
I don't know if anybody's watching them,
you know,
wow.
Money.
I'm not making it.
And just,
it was this tiny movie where none of them were making any money.
I turn a Todd Phillips and I go,
how would you make them for this movie?
I mean,
you know,
he makes good money.
He goes,
you're making more than I am.
I say,
what do you mean?
He goes,
I deferred my salary for a back end and I remember literally thinking to myself,
I went,
whatever dude,
you're out of your mind.
No stars.
It's a movie called the hangover in Vegas.
Also wound has to do now is be good.
If it's good,
people talk about it just through networking,
Facebook and Twitter and just find out about shit.
What you don't put the,
well I don't,
maybe you can,
maybe you have a theory on why the hangover was a phenomenal thing because it
was awesome because it was fun because people want to see it and they had a good
time.
It's that simple.
Yeah,
it was a really,
I mean it was a really kind of almost like a cliche subject going to Vegas and
going crazy and partying.
We wake up,
what happened?
What went wrong?
But it was done so well.
Every part about it.
It was great.
The acting was great.
The stores were fun.
They were,
they were silly but yet believable enough.
Phillips knows how to make a movie.
That guy great basically wrote and directed bad Santa and the radios that that
was him.
They gave him a 40 minute like a thing in Harvey Weinstein was like,
Ah,
you got to save this movie.
And he basically went back and rewrote and re did the whole thing and shot at.
That guy's crazy.
He's only Bob Thorton.
Oh,
oh yeah,
yeah.
That guy's a nice guy.
Really,
really nice guy but definitely likes in Canada.
And it was on this really cool radio show and I think it's in Toronto and the
guy was talking to him or the guy introduces him in the band and just for
context states that this guy's a um,
you know,
Academy Award winning actor and just,
to try to like layer the store that this guy's a bad motherfucker.
Right,
right.
Just giving him his props.
Billy Bob goes into a hissy fit because the guy was not supposed to mention
acting.
So he there you may believe for living dude.
Exactly.
I'm not even like,
I'm a musician.
Do you not understand?
I'm a musician and you know,
he's like,
you know,
just like answering his questions all fucked up and we're just trying to throw
the guy off and the guy handles it.
Amazingly.
The guy just totally like rational talking,
you know?
Totally calm.
Makes it through without any freak outs.
I mean,
here he's got this fucking world famous,
you know,
Academy Award winning actor who's clearly been crazy,
right?
Like a mad at him because he mentioned that he happened to win an Oscar,
I think,
five times.
Right?
I mean,
think about that for a second,
you know,
I mean,
come on guys.
How crazy is Brad Pitt?
Brad Pitt does not look at Angelina Jolie and goes,
wait a minute,
how nutty is this bitch?
She fucked this guy.
It used to take his blood and wear it around her neck.
Okay,
what if I'm at what's going on here?
It's probably really stung going,
dude,
you got blood around your,
and you know,
like he's,
I think she just worked him.
I think she came in,
I think she is an Alpha fucking female vaginal Predator kind of thing.
She just grabbed him,
held him down and made a meter pussy and that was it.
Yeah,
she don,
she shot him off.
Yeah.
Middle by now.
And they're like,
oh,
our goes away.
What power?
And her being able to be like,
oh,
I wish you made magic.
Maybe we just match it.
No,
no,
I was,
I don't mean to dis Brad Pitt and I don't really have anything against him,
but I was listening to Larry King once and Larry King was talking to Scott.
I was like,
fuck is this dummy?
And turned out to me Brad Pitt.
I was listening in my car.
I had no idea who the fuck it was.
I was like,
this guy's an idiot.
Yeah.
Larry King's talk to me.
What does this guy do it,
we'll be right back with Brad Pitt.
And I was like,
wow,
Brad Pitt is dumb.
I mean,
look,
he's a fucking actor.
He doesn't have to be smart and maybe he is smart.
He's just not smarter taught nobody ever.
I always say,
well the answer might be,
I mean some people come off badly and interviews.
I know I had,
he's a simple guy.
I think he's a simple guy who had a certain bone structure that cut light well
and he was,
his strength is he's not afraid to look bad and not afraid to take chances.
He keeps trying to be really good and I think he's a really good actor.
Like I thought it was awesome and interview with a vampire that's like one of my
favorite roles ever.
Roll now and become a victim to his good looks like he's always trying to do
something different and his production company makes a lot of money.
It does really makes really good movies.
I'm not saying he really is a retarded,
I really do enjoy is acting.
I think you just thought a fight club.
When I was listening to him I was like,
because he's a movie star
and intelligence.
Well it's also,
it's not even that.
It's just usually it's the ability to project.
A lot of times people,
they can be smart,
just they're not that good at stringing words together and you know,
and coming off smart,
very positive.
You know,
also intelligence is compartmentalize.
You can be very smart in one area and not smart at all.
And I think that with someone like Brad Pitt,
I don't think it ever made it was ever relevant for him until probably recently
with Angelina Jolie to even read a whole lot about other things.
You know,
when you're a prince and Hollywood and you're spending a lot of time on set,
you can,
you can create deficits that way or not filling the holes you need to.
One of the things that I loved about Brian when I first met him,
it was like,
here's this guy who was an actor who wasn't like actors cause I'd only been in
Hollywood,
but I met Brian for about a year and I was just sick of it.
I was ready to go back home.
I was ready to quit,
quit acting and go uh,
and a and just go back to standup comedy in New York.
I just didn't like actors.
And then I got news radio and then I decided to stay and then I met Brian.
But he was like the first actor that I met that wasn't like an actor cause we're
both on news radio.
At one time he played my brother Nick Depaulo putting my other brother.
That was awesome.
But when,
you know,
when,
when I first came on the site,
here's a perfect example,
Brian and I were,
were hanging out in this cafeteria and we were eating and uh,
Brian was doing some impression or something and I was laughing fucking
hysterically.
It was really funny shit.
And this other guy who was the actor who's on the show with this as well,
was trying just to top Brian kept trying to top him like everything Brian would
say.
He'd be like Janette,
he'd be like,
man,
pitch.
I got shit.
And it was like really loud and trying too hard.
And second sharp f.
When you're listening to a and somebody's going pro with a horn,
you're like,
Ooh,
it's blowing that horn over there.
It was just,
you know,
immediately I could see like,
okay,
here's,
here's an actor.
This isn't,
that guy's an actor.
That's what they're like,
you know,
or any,
any of those really creepy,
needy Hollywood people.
They wouldn't have to be an actor.
You know,
you could be a comic and be like that.
You could be,
you could be anything,
but you'd be a singer and be like that.
But it's that creepy needy enter.
It has to do with not having perspective and putting yourself at the center of
the universe.
That's what a lot of actors do.
Like they actually think that what they're doing and what they think and what
they have to say is historically relevant.
And that comes from being a self involved to the nth degree,
which in some ways I feel almost you need for free sometimes to be an,
that also is because of the environment on sets of when you're on a set,
everyone's kissing your ass.
You are,
if you're the star of your,
you know,
like some big guy and you're on a set,
everyone is relying on you to pay their bills.
Your success means that,
you know,
they get to keep their job and they get to buy a new house.
So they're always kissing the actresses like you're treated like roots.
Ridiculous.
You could,
you could be wrong about things.
People won't argue and you see it,
you see it like all the time.
Yeah.
So people create their own eating on create their own reality and then everybody
kind of enters into this mutual agreement that they're going out,
they're gonna,
they're gonna sort of keep your reality a reality,
especially when,
you know,
if you're working long hours,
which they are in a lot of movies and especially like a lot of our TV shows,
they work long ass fucking hours and people get cranky.
And when you get cranky,
want to just yell to get things done,
well that starts a precedent.
And then they,
they,
they get used to yelling at people and then it becomes,
they're allowed to yell at people.
Then it becomes,
oh,
here's that crazy actor.
He's running everything.
Everybody quiet,
quiet,
quiet.
So they get this completely distorted perception of where they fit in the real
circle of life.
It's fucking pretenders,
but they're locked in this weird social system that like rewards it.
Have you guys met John Lithgo and what does he like?
I'm,
I have,
I read,
I did a,
um,
I auditioned with him once and he read with me.
It was kind of exciting.
He was on third rock from the sun when I was on news radio.
I've got to meet him at one of those NBC press junket things.
Yeah.
He's a cool dude.
He's a real actor and he does a lot of states still in New York and,
and a very nice guy.
A really,
really,
who's that guy from Fargo?
The guy would,
Joe Montana.
Who's that guy?
What's his name?
Oh,
Bill.
Bill Macy.
Bill Mason.
Yeah.
Hilarious actor.
Really,
really,
really awesome.
Actually,
I met him once and uh,
I said,
hey man,
I really love that movie you did with Joe,
Monta [inaudible]
and he just,
he makes this Joe Joe Montana.
W how was his name?
Joe Montana.
Yeah.
My tenure.
So he goes,
it's a Joe Montana.
So he says that to me and I'm like,
God,
I'm not fucking idiot guys saying you really like something and say,
yeah,
I mean it's like one of the few guys that ever want to meet.
I mean Fargo is one of my favorite movies ever.
So like me meeting him was like,
wow,
really meeting this guy.
And he's like,
it's chill Tanya.
Like,
oh sorry guys,
I gotta go
now.
Just so such a piece of shit.
I mean you make to,
he is thinking he's the guy from the sopranos.
Oh,
pussy.
Yeah.
They're always think of Joey Diaz as big pussy.
Pronto's that's funny.
Well,
so what,
I mean,
what was it like for you coming into Hollywood and dealing with all these actor
type human beings?
Because it is like,
it's really is for people who don't know,
for people who have regular,
regular jobs,
it is shocking when you're,
when you first get around actor,
it's shocking.
Yeah.
Because they're telling you two plus two is 16 and and it,
it's just the weirdest world money.
They're all democrats,
all of them.
Because I believe that there's such thing as being able to socially engineer
equality quality and that that Washington knows what to do with your mind.
They think that,
I think they think that the left is the best.
They think that going left and and being like this socially aware person makes
you look cooler in Hollywood.
It's like a mindset that they adopt without really considering any of the
different aspects of that mindset.
It's just,
it's a Hollywood theme.
Right.
I was going to say it a lot of times I find that they don't know that there's an
alternative out there.
They don't know that.
Just saying,
you know,
just because you're not left wing doesn't mean you're a quote unquote
Republican.
Do you know Tracy,
when you hear a wheeze,
when you hear like people go like they talk about the Democratic Party,
like,
wow,
we've got to win this guy.
Yeah.
It's like you're thinking like it's the Dodgers.
So also it's a collectivist mindset,
which if you look at history,
has never really produced any results at all.
The,
the what makes this country great is individuals who take a chance and get
rewarded for it.
Come on,
coming up with ideas and,
and,
and in a way that's actually the best way to create a community.
Yeah.
I mean it should have to rely on each other as a broad spectrum of ideas.
To lump them into two competing camps is absolutely ridiculous,
especially when people just jump on either camp and everything they say is
Gospel and you're in the Andrew Tall if you don't believe exactly.
You said it.
It's like team,
it's like two different teams when you listen or watch the elections,
our team versus your team and,
and any of your ideas be damned because my team's going to win.
My favorite guy that I know that I used to know who was a,
a,
a real like liberal leftist,
like really like everything.
Liberals wanted reparations for slavery,
for Real,
um,
believed that what he called himself a feminist.
I'm not bullshitting.
He calls himself a fandom us in when he was married.
Uh,
I believe he even changed his name.
He changed his wife's name,
hyphenated,
and her name was last.
Oh,
what's trying to reinvent the wheel?
He hyphenated and not,
she hyphenated,
hyphenated his own name and accepted hers last,
it's like the dominant name.
That's like the hot tub time machine.
Two Great.
This guy was like,
his body was made of Jello.
His hands were frail and tiny and his testosterone hips were odd.
He had none.
He had not,
he walked funny.
There's like a funny walked him.
He,
he,
he just had no ability to get out of the way of anything,
but that's like his way of making themselves feel significant was his game.
His game was,
you know,
I am going to support your rights as a woman more than a man than a,
than other women will.
I will do it as a man.
Yeah.
That's my,
that's his rap.
Yes,
that's right.
It's all,
it's all,
it's all like,
that's that he figured out that that got him laid a couple of times and then
just bought into it.
That's all he had available.
What is it going to do is either going to do that or going to collect guns.
You that's just good too.
And he's got one of the other bro,
you gotta to go one extra.
You're gonna,
you're compensating whether you like it or not.
You Dick is an inch long and you're made of Jello.
All right.
You're compensated disaster.
The,
he was my favorite example of someone who was just like this guy was like wood
tree.
You could not have a discussion about something.
You know,
you could not have a discussion about,
you know,
war.
You could not have a discussion about politics,
anything that involved,
you know,
the Democrats and the Republicans.
You could not have it.
Cause as soon as you had an opposing point of view,
we'll like,
you don't think that maybe it's a good idea to pay attention to really radical
groups all over the world.
You don't think that may be is a good idea.
And that's maybe kept people safe.
You fucking right wing the Andrew Hall's so he shuts you down.
Oh yeah.
Immediately built a wall around you.
And so now you're on that name calling and defines you and it's always,
you know,
right wing,
which I am the last person to be right wing or anyway,
I always,
I always reject.
um,
I,
I'm more of a libertarian.
I've just always believed that,
that I believe that human beings know how to govern themselves.
I think you have to have a certain amount of government.
I believe you have to have roads and you have to have a strong defense.
You have to have police force.
I believe in that stuff.
However,
I think we are,
and I don't want to say we're headed toward this trend,
but I think that the danger is always been,
and George Washington said that people will invent lost to take their own power
away from them.
Uh,
W W W we're always,
there's always a danger that a centralized bureaucracy will get enough power,
become a leviathan where it just starts needing more and more resources and then
you lose your freedoms.
You do in the name of making the world a better place.
It's always a benevolent,
a concept behind it.
But,
um,
I,
I think that the best way to look at things is when people say you're a
conservative.
Well,
I was,
I don't like that.
I don't like when people say that because what they're saying is that I am
somehow,
um,
it has in its connotation the idea that I am a very stodgy and very strict and
very controlling.
Whereas I'm actually quite the opposite.
I believe I'm,
I'm,
you could call me right wings,
certainly not left wing because I believe in maximum personal freedom.
I believe you should legalize drugs because I think people know essentially how
to govern themselves and if they don't,
there are people going to drugs anyway.
That's just one example.
But I think for the most part,
um,
you government should be treated like a necessary evil,
not a huge engine for good cause.
The only problem with legalizing drugs is that if this is,
this is a,
I mean this is an argument and I'm not exactly sure I support it,
but this is the argument.
The argument is that if you made drugs legal than big corporations would step in
and be even more out of control because they would realize that the real money
is in selling people these drugs that used to be illegal and they would package
them and make them very cheap and very available.
And because of the fact there'd be so much of it because there'd be profit in it
that people would do it that wouldn't ordinarily do it.
I don't necessarily buy it,
but I do think that you have to be really careful of allowing anybody to make a
living or make money or get rich off of something that can fuck other people up.
Cigarettes,
cigarettes,
and alcohol.
Say Pimps.
The people that are sound cigarettes right now,
look,
I know there's billions and billions of dollars in cigarettes,
but you know what the fuck you're doing.
You know what the fuck you're doing,
period.
There's no debate anymore.
This isn't 1950s with those camel ads on TV or putting your doctor recommends
camels.
You know,
it's not that you're,
you're fucking yourself for sure and you're making billions of dollars off
people fucking themselves.
But don't you think that there's always going to be a segment of the population
that is going to just abuse themselves?
I think that certain people do drugs and whether or not they're legal or not,
it may would probably raise the,
that the,
um,
the usage maybe.
But for the most part,
I think when people who want to get high,
they find a way to get home.
It's true.
But the idea that you can profit off that,
I think,
I don't,
I don't think you should be able to profit off of fucking people over.
People are profiting now.
You know,
I know the local drug dealers,
so no,
I don't think that should be legal.
Um,
I think,
you know,
I'm all for drugs being a statement.
Yeah.
I'm all,
I'm all for drugs,
being legal.
I'm not for,
you know,
I'm totally for social dog Darwinism,
but I can see this as an argument.
That's all I'm saying.
I'm not saying that I support it.
I'm saying,
I can see the argument that if you did,
there would be more access.
There would be more of an end,
you would have even more of a problem than we have already have.
Corporations being basically sociopathic,
you know,
not caring,
but he's top of the head of every,
you know,
these questions are getting only more and more relevant and deeper and deeper
and,
and this is the other issue.
We are now coming out with technology.
The genie's out of the bottle.
We're coming up with technology that has potential,
do incredible good,
but incredibly be also be incredibly destructive.
For example,
is scientists are now learning how to create new life forms at of synthetic
material that's,
that have never existed.
And they're creating self replicating proteins.
What does that mean?
That means that at the in 2030 40 years,
nobody knows,
but this stuff is moving exponentially.
You're going have,
you're probably going to have computers,
machines,
whatever you want to call them,
that replicate themselves,
right?
Yeah.
What do you do?
What is the dialogue and what are the questions that accompany that w what?
What is to say that these machines won't,
we'll have a respect for their biological heritage.
You tell me,
is there a guarantee?
There probably isn't.
No,
there's no guarantee.
And if they become intelligent and they developed some sort of a self defense
mechanism,
then it's like skynet.
That's what I mean really.
That's what every computer scientist,
that is the conversation that guys like Ray Kurzweil and these computer
scientists are talking about.
Yeah.
It's a real conversation that's not being addressed anywhere else when people
are talking about Lindsay Lohan going to jail.
Well exactly,
exactly.
And that's the tidal wave that's coming that nobody sees.
Very few people see that,
that we're gonna.
I think we're,
our futures are going to be so radically altered in the next 20 years.
I think ways we can't even comprehend.
I don't think we even aware of how radical the changes have been that have taken
place in our life.
Right.
Things are gradual.
You get used to it.
You know,
we used to the fact that we're doing this thing right now and you know,
thousands of people listening to it live and it's going out all over the world
as a podcast,
hundreds of thousands of people,
and it's through just to fucking sitting in a room in my house.
Well,
by the way,
the Internet is just 5,000 days old.
They Internet is 5,000 days old.
Nobody.
And there were people that were never realized,
put it into context,
but if you think about the,
how long,
it's been around for 15 years,
that's 5,000 days.
A little over 5,000 days.
So,
so the Internet has just been around for 5,000 days now.
What's going to happen in 20,000 days?
She's crying about how fast this stuff is moving.
Yeah.
It's,
it's staggering.
it's hard to really wrap your head around it.
It's hard to wrap your head around the fact that 200 years ago,
the best way to get around was derived and animal to,
which by the way,
is a lot sexier than a high.
Wanted a picture of someone.
You had to draw it.
Yeah.
There was no cameras 200 years ago.
That's incredible.
It's just incredible.
That's two lifetimes,
two lifetimes,
and everything's right.
We changed.
Yeah.
The Internet's totally like a drug nowadays.
They're going to find a way to sell the internet to you,
like a drug a little bit.
You know?
I just can't believe that the government's not like grabbing a hold of the
Internet and trying to make as much money as possible out of it.
It can.
The government,
it'll be a problem.
As you look at it as the government,
the government,
but the government,
it's like it would be great if there was only like 10 people in the earth and
there was like two dudes and they were the government.
Then that would work,
but the same people that would profit off drugs.
Then the same people that would profit off.
Well,
how would they do that?
Brian would a sensor it.
They would know.
I don't think Congress,
I mean you're talking about,
first of all the government,
the government is,
is this several different ways.
It's about 50 different competing entities.
Right?
I don't think it's possible,
but I'm just saying that it's amazing that they know,
which brings up the subject that I wanted to talk about HR five,
seven,
four one slavery.
This is that.
Yeah.
Charlie rangle.
I think that's how he started saying wrangle.
Yeah.
He,
uh,
proposing this build that everyone served two years of service mandatory
service,
whether it'd be in the military or military support.
No.
And the reason why he's proposing this is because he believes that the war is
wrong and that he wants to,
uh,
make a point by if these congressmen aren't willing to go themselves,
if they're not willing to send their family and their loved ones,
then they shouldn't be supporting this war.
Which is,
it's very fair.
It makes sense.
But the problem is it's still,
it's like you can't even offer that up as an option.
As a rational option.
You can't offer up two years mandatory service.
Fuck you asshole.
No,
fuck you.
To make a point.
You know,
if you want to make a point,
do with your mouth.
Don't propose shit that when slave people [inaudible] that's not gonna work.
But it works the way it works.
It works here in Israel.
We had it here for a long time.
We had a mandatory draft until the 19 cc that was a draft.
That's a little bit different.
This is service for every single person.
Everyone's doing countries.
Everyone served two years.
Mandatory minimum.
Yeah.
But you know,
good luck Charlie.
I mean,
good luck trying to get,
that's not going to get it passed and I don't think he wants to get it passed
but by people may in a point.
But even that point suggesting that is,
that's like fucking treason.
I just put it out there that that's a rational argument.
Your,
you are lowering the standards of opposition.
You're saying,
you know,
if,
I mean,
if you're supposed to be the thing that's protecting us from the military
industrial complex and the global machine,
it's supposed to be our elected representatives and our elected representatives
are proposing that everyone be enslaved by the fucking country and being forced
to do two years of mandatory service,
no matter what your job is.
Fuck you.
Exactly.
By the way,
by the way,
that's exactly what I'm talking about.
Government will,
if you give,
if you allow government to,
and I'm talking about just any,
any Leviathan,
any,
any huge court,
they,
they will,
they will take your power away from you to laundry shows that time and time
again.
It doesn't have to be right or left wing about that.
That's just a,
that's to open a history book.
History runs on momentum and the problem is the arc.
Our Society is so complex that 90% of the people,
90% of the time are doing shit that they don't want to be doing to support the
machine.
The machine is that big.
That's right.
It's so we'll think about what,
when taxes are 48% in some brackets or,
or,
well actually in this country that 38% 38% of your day is working for the
government.
You're 38% of your time,
you are working for someone else and you never see the benefits of that.
You think that those tax money that you've already paid taxes on it,
you get taxed again when you buy things in sales times.
Exactly.
Oh and by the way,
when you want to leave your inheritance to your kids,
you get that gets taxed by the way at 60 that you've already been taxed and your
social security,
if you die before your social security,
the government gets that money,
your family doesn't get that money.
So all that money you're putting away,
you better live till you're 65 and then you get it in increments.
So there are a lot of,
there are a lot of issues that that um,
but isn't this the main issue?
There's too many people.
That's the main issue.
The main issue is this thing is gigantic and it's totally out of control.
And one of the reasons why is that there's too many of us,
people have been saying that for a long time.
And I think that's certainly an issue and it's a,
but I happen to believe that human beings with technology in their imagination
will be able to accommodate the 9 billion people that are coming in the next 15
years.
I mean,
I a billion more,
no,
a will be,
it will be at 9 billion in about 15 years from,
from most projections.
In fact,
most of the populations,
including the Middle East,
the mean age is 35 years old.
So there are a lot of competent countries are actually have stable or negative
population growth.
Um,
even in Africa they just did,
uh,
they just,
eh,
these invest invest like Moody's or something said that Africa African bonds are
actually worth investing in because huge swaths of Africa and now seeing the
middleclass 360 million of them have cell phones.
What,
that,
what comes with that is less children.
Because as people move into cities and away from rural,
they don't have as many children.
And so,
so what's been surprising that nobody predicted in the 70s when you had things
like the population bomb that was written and things is that population in a lot
of countries,
especially Europe and now more and more in the Middle East has actually started
to stabilize and declined.
Germany has a zero population growth,
zero zero Mexico,
Mexico,
which a lot of people think,
well that,
you know,
they're exploding the population because they have a lot of children here.
Mexico now is down to,
I believe 2.6 children,
a couple when it used to be literally,
you know,
eight nine.
So people,
people as they,
as they get access to information,
say I want more from me.
Why do I want [inaudible]?
Friends are fucking crazy with kids.
It's funny that that's like an insult somehow or another,
you know,
if you say something about Mexicans,
we'll just go like eight kids and I really,
oh,
what are you racist?
Like no,
Mexicans have a lot of kids and kids are awesome.
Why is it a bad thing to have a lot of kids too?
You know,
I love kids.
I love having kids.
They're awesome.
Like if you got eight,
I'm not hating on you,
but why is it funny that you know,
if you're Mexican,
you have kids,
you say that and be like,
oh yeah,
asshole.
Yeah.
Well that as well.
No certain cultural,
certain cultural,
uh,
sort of Ma and things are,
are very resilient.
It's like black people with chicken and watermelon.
Why is that bad?
Chicken and watermelon are both awesome.
Yeah,
no,
I love him.
I love watermelon.
It's fucking delicious.
And I love chicken.
How come you can't bring up,
you know,
if you get a black waiter,
I'd like some chicken and watermelon that there'll be some tension.
A lot of that comes back to,
you know,
in the,
in the fifties,
in the south,
they would make posters of a black Joe,
you know,
as far as I know where it all comes from,
but it's 2010.
Why are we hanging on to that?
Yeah,
man,
chicken is awesome,
right?
Fried chicken tastes awesome and watermelon tastes awesome.
Take all of those,
take the power away.
The power away from chicken and watermelon.
That's ridiculous.
I can't wait.
Did they combined the two?
Although I'm not a fan of the grape soda.
Not really great.
A great crushing of bottles.
You know what and said he has a joke where he,
where he says that that brothers are,
um,
the one thing that one place they're not cool.
Like they're usually really way cooler than white people.
And he goes,
and I heard,
I was watched a bunch of black guys in the audience just die over this.
He goes,
the one place you guys are not cool is when you,
when you see a magic trick,
like when they see magically,
like
they jump around,
they run out of the room and come back and stuff.
It was so fun and it's is funny.
Oh God.
Yeah.
He's a good dude.
He's another good,
that's a really good guy.
Not like a comedian.
No.
Brett.
Brett's in very normal dude.
He is.
That's the,
there's just,
there's not that many,
there's more comics that are like,
that then are actors for sure.
Comics are much more humbled by life.
You know,
it's today it's much more difficult,
you know,
I'll have to be more grounded.
Say about La.
When I first came,
you know,
I had been Mike Childhood,
I'd grown up in the seven different countries.
You know,
I was born in the Philippines.
You had a really interesting life.
I don't know how much of it you're allowed to talk about.
We'll talk about your dad.
No,
no,
but no,
but I was,
I was,
I was bounced around many different countries.
I mean,
I didn't live in the same place until I was,
uh,
15,
for,
for a year.
I mean,
we've got,
I was Saudi Arabia,
Lebanon,
Pakistan creased India,
the Philippines that will be constantly bounced around and then two and then me
wet.
I know.
Thank you so much.
What the well,
I am,
I'm very mysterious.
Little knows Brian was the other voice in,
um,
my,
uh,
getting pumped,
audio clip,
if you've heard it,
like stern used to play it all the time.
Like Mikey and this guy was in the basement.
Come on your ass looks awesome.
Come on,
turn around and muscular.
We,
uh,
we did that.
It was,
that was him and I though that was a over at a Warner brothers with Ginger Lynn
[inaudible].
Yeah.
Yeah,
but you guys need to make a sequel to that.
I will.
I wrote,
I wrote one where they wind up sucking each other off cause they shave each
other's balls.
And I'm like,
you know,
I don't think my,
I'm thinking about getting Dick Surgery like,
Oh,
do you get tick is awesome.
It's huge.
You know what you need to do?
You need to shave your pubes like shave your pubes.
Yeah,
Shave your pubes me.
She can't check mine out.
Look at that.
It's all shaped.
My Dick looks way bigger.
Right?
I don't remember what it used to look like.
Come on,
let me see what your Boomi see.
We got there.
It pulls his pants down.
He's got like all this pubes like,
oh,
can I can't even see your tickets a fucking,
it's a forest in here.
We've got to start trimming and then he trims it down.
It's like,
wow,
that kind of tickles.
Look,
he could Cox huge now it doesn't,
I swear to God,
I think I would start gagging if I had that Dick in my mouth.
And then they start face fucking each other and it's like really violent is
in a straight away.
And this was a story that I wrote about on my blog.
It's an absolute true story.
Um,
a buddy of mine was a director of porno films and he invited us to a porno
party,
me and a bunch of guys from Jujitsu.
So we get there and we're like,
we were thinking,
well,
what is a porno party going to be like?
It's all porno stars.
Like there's going to be a freak show,
right?
Yeah.
We get their notes.
All dudes.
Okay.
It's all dudes and people who work for the,
it's basically like the wrap party and a few girls show up.
Okay.
And uh,
that was the one we went to.
So hobbies,
things.
So they say,
so they say sit down,
we're about to everybody please be seated.
We're about to start the movie and it's this movie,
this like it's art porn and it's like real acting.
And real plots with porn.
So it's death.
Okay.
I mean the acting is the worst ever projecting it on the side of a building by
the way,
really blurry.
So while all this is going on,
this one chick,
I won't even say her name,
she's getting fucking plowed on the screen.
This guy is just fucking her face.
He's just got her mounted and I guess that's her thing.
And she likes to gag and shit.
So while this all was going on,
someone goes,
she's here.
So she pulls up and a guy gets out of the car and then she gets out of the car
and the guy starts walking towards this screen with this look on his face.
Like he cannot fucking believe what he's saying is their first shades.
This,
this guy's going ass to mouth on her.
He's going ass
mouth,
mouth and his,
every time we fuck her in the ass and be like this like hard,
like you could hear his ball slapping off of her ass.
It was like the way I described like to chalkboard or racers.
So he's like fuck her ass.
And then our mouth when he's fucking her mouth.
It's like she's an odd,
it's like,
oh,
and this dude is just fucking fucking ass.
Fucking her mouth fucking ass.
I mean it is brutal.
It's brutal.
Fuck spitting in her face.
I mean it's fucking hard core and this kid is looking at this and his jaw is
totally dropped and I start like inching towards him.
I'm like,
I want to know if this kid knows.
Does he know this can't be possible?
No idea.
Had no idea.
There was that first day.
It was their first day.
She told him that she was a makeup artist and she took him to a fucking porn.
She didn't know they're going to be playing her life.
None on,
no,
she did not on the side of a building.
Somehow or another she thought he wasn't going to find out that she's a porno
star.
So she goes,
I was going to tell you,
that's exactly how she said it like this.
Oh,
it's going to tell you.
And,
and then we grabbed the guy and we interviewed him and I took pictures of them
and share what held it together.
Dude.
The guy was wondering if remarkably I think,
you know,
immediately the poor guy look,
she was hot as fuck and the poor guy probably thought like,
wow,
I got a real hottie that's fucked up that she didn't say anything.
She's fucked up.
She's [inaudible].
Yeah.
But yeah,
no,
like just STDs alone.
Tell somebody nothing happened.
I mean,
she doesn't have any responsibility until they fuck.
Maybe she wasn't going to get them.
Our Pal,
who I can't name,
um,
uh,
had a,
a hot date with a porn star.
He thought he got over to her place and um,
you know,
hey,
you want to come over and smoke a little pot?
Sure.
So he goes over place,
um,
smoked a little pot with her,
tries to bust a move and she's like,
no,
no.
I just want us to be smoking buddies.
And so I get you for your amazing conversation.
Oh,
that's the worst ever.
It was going to be your smoking budget right there.
And that must be,
this must have been very similar to how this,
well,
this guy must have felt a lot worse,
but he probably felt like got this hot girl.
She's super hot.
I'm going to go to her party at work.
Fuck it.
She's so hot.
Look at her body.
My God.
And then he gets out of the car.
Well,
you're trying to show me you're a good girl now.
Fuck.
It's like you were so close.
Know.
Fuck.
And I'm the one guy.
You don't fuck.
I'm the one guy to you.
Bang Stranger.
She's hot as fuck.
He's beaten off to all the time waiting for this.
Oh yeah.
I'm going to have this pot date.
We're going to hang out with
kiss overplays Tara.
Sorry.
I just want to be smoking buddy.
That's awful.
Sorry.
Tired of sex or this little tiny skirt throw you off and these 10 inch heels.
Did she really think that I was going to fuck you?
Oh my God,
that makes me,
Oh my God.
I'm not like,
that makes me angry.
He's a,
if you're a woman and you do porn,
you have to make it really clear
with dudes.
The can't fuck you.
Yeah.
Oh,
by the way,
you can't fuck me.
Yeah.
You know,
you can't just ask.
Never going to work either.
Come on over my house and smoked some weed at night.
Oh,
okay.
You figure.
Yeah.
What's going to happen there?
You want a massage?
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
We'll stop off and pick up some condoms.
Oh,
squirt and lotion on her back and the finger.
My asshole.
What finger you asshole.
I just want to be smoking buddies.
Who's alarm clock went off?
Why heels write him up.
I gotta go to work and this is like a real porn girl guy.
Porn Star.
Oh fuck yes.
I don't remember who it is.
Oh Gee.
She's a fucking,
she's a of talented performer.
Yeah.
High heels and Liz shitting in my favorite shit.
Why?
The guys always want a straight guys always pretend they're like a joke around
in a gay way.
It's so funny.
That's a gross thing.
And my Buddy Chris Delea sends me pictures sometimes.
It's funny.
Yeah.
You know,
Christa,
Leah,
right.
Crystally awareness as a young comic.
Really Funny Guy.
And I'll get pictures on my cell phone and it'll just be,
hey,
a picture of his legs,
his stonewashed jeans with kind of like just the bowl to of his pants and has to
be a close up shot.
He's,
you know,
just be like,
keep up the good work,
Brian.
Just some innocuous or then I got a picture the other day on my phone and he's
got his heart on wrapped in a sheet is holding them on a sheet like that and,
and,
and the caption says,
dude,
there's a ghost in my room.
Oh,
fuck yeah.
Okay,
I'm glad we put that in the podcast.
Some of these to put that in the movie.
Oh,
it was the funniest thing in the world.
Pay Him or put him in the movie and have him show up.
And he's like,
hey.
And he's got his phone.
I walk into his phone and that's him holding his dog.
He's got a little fluffy white dog with glasses on and half a heart on standing
arching his chest like that with his dog.
I went,
oh,
what are you doing?
And then he walked by me as I was talking to take his phone and rub it across my
face.
I was like,
ah,
this is a strange thing.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
If it wasn't for gay people,
we would be missing a big chunk of the phone in our culture.
Absolutely Elton John's style sunglasses,
and they search the trends.
Let's start the fashion trends,
man.
You guys about Dad's gay.
And then four years later they're like,
where are they?
What's really funny is like,
Gee,
you know Rob Halford is like the originator of all that,
like leather fucking dominatrix type shit.
You know the way he dresses on stage and he was gay,
he was gay and he got all these people to dress like him.
It's fantastic.
I mean,
how many people dressed the way they dressed?
You know,
they wanted to be like rockers because of Rob Halford from Judas priest.
Yeah,
fucking a lot of them.
He was gay.
Gay as fuck.
So was Pete Townsend Townsend?
It did a lot of shit.
Pete Townsend I guess is,
I don't know if he's gay or ed did a lot of gay shit.
He said he knows what it's like to be a woman.
Yeah.
He said,
yeah,
I know.
And I remember Roger Daltrey heard that.
Yeah.
And Roger Daltrey was like,
ah,
ah.
That's how I thought we weren't talking about this.
I,
uh,
Pete Townsend fucked a couple of guys who got fucked.
I Bet Daltrey tried it too.
I bet they all did it.
I mean,
look,
there's always that college stuff flies out of his speedo.
All of a sudden I'm gay.
They get raped on Oz.
I didn't,
I did not.
I wasn't my plenty off story that we probably can't tell.
Yeah.
Story.
That was probably,
that was a weird situation while you were there.
So you saw it and I got vindicated in the end.
Of course you did.
Yeah.
And I do.
I was like,
here's a situation that happened.
Um,
Brian had a friend and the friend,
uh,
had a lady friend that happened to be an exotic dancer.
Okay.
And we went to,
told me to go,
he told him to go to visit her at her place of employment.
And you saw the girl may called the B line for me and stuff,
dancing,
not just dancing.
She was,
she hopped on top of Brian and immediately straddled her vagina ont his deck and
started gyrating her pussy.
And you're saying,
you're saying this girl wants a bangle?
I go,
I know,
but I don't have clearance from my friend yet.
I don't know if it's allowed,
but I think it's insinuated,
but I still wasn't going to do it because you can't.
It was ridiculous.
So,
um,
you know,
I think you asked me to go with you when you dropped her off.
She felt uncomfortable.
Yes,
I want you to come because you got a headache.
Come out of here.
I was like,
dude,
you come with me because I'm,
this is bad because she's going to give me a ride and it's my girls,
my boys girl.
And it just doesn't look good.
So I don't know if he turned into the wolf man after I left.
No,
no,
I was at the shareholders.
But can you say what she accused you of?
Yeah.
Uh,
she accused me of making,
like getting rough with her.
Actually I found out later,
I didn't even know that was an acquisition shit that I actually got physical
with her and tried to,
you know,
make her,
have a kiss me and fool around with her and stuff like that,
which is kind of like saying the guy tried to rape me,
you know what I mean?
At least when people hear that they go,
the guy's a closet rapist.
But what happened was,
uh,
it was the Hilton or the Sheridan and um,
I was on the third floor,
which actually means that the lobby,
it's on the lobby,
the third floor.
And so,
um,
I said,
she said,
let me use your bathroom.
When she dropped me off,
she goes,
I need to use your bathroom instead of using the bathroom in the lobby.
I need to use your bathroom.
And we'd go to my room and I go,
I'm dead.
She's in my room now.
This is bad.
And by the way,
I'm an animal.
I'm not,
I'm not saying I'm not a good guy.
I mean I,
I,
it's like I'm a 12 stepper.
I mean,
you've got to grow in my high and my,
and my hotel.
I dance on me all night and nobody's watching danger.
Yeah.
And by the way,
even if I do full around with my friend better,
forgive me because I'm just a guy.
If he's like me,
right,
he shouldn't be attached to her anyway.
She's Koresh you doing what's correct.
Correct.
But,
but I,
I thought maybe that would have been you were thinking like,
I think he might want me to fuck her.
Why else would it be to me?
But she's this crazy.
Exactly.
But you know,
then she's in my room and I go,
I start acting.
I started doing,
I got nervous.
So I started acting silly.
I was,
I was joking around and she could tell because she wanted some wine.
So do you have any wine?
And my mini bar and I poured the one,
I go,
this is how it's going to start.
This is getting bad.
I'm already guilty.
I'm done.
So I start,
she goes,
a,
you're a freak,
aren't you?
You're a freak or something like that.
And I go,
yeah,
I'm a freak and I start doing this.
And I said,
I thought out,
I'm a freak and she can see that I'm nervous.
And she goes,
are you going to go back and tell such and such that I was in your room?
And I go,
no,
I'm not.
Actually,
I'm not at all.
In fact,
here's my last 20 bucks.
So I spent all my money on you,
which was really inappropriate anyway.
And I remember was 20 bucks.
I go give this to the valet and we'll just say that you dropped me off.
That would be way better for me because this is already bad.
Sorry.
That situation she gets up,
goes out.
And,
uh,
the next day,
or I guess that weekend I'd booked that CBS show,
but I go back to Oz and,
uh,
I literally,
nobody will look at me.
And then I got written out and the that,
and I was,
I was the person that this happened.
It was a huge scene.
He tried to,
he was like,
the girl told him and he was like,
you know,
he didn't know.
He thought this guy put up with me.
She was crying.
Well,
she didn't want was what she did.
Why was that?
She came back to your room.
She had a 12 year old child.
She had a meal ticket and all of a sudden,
because she makes this mistake,
she had to sell somebody down.
Somebody going down the river,
not her daughter.
It's going to be me.
Right.
And so I never held any,
I honestly never held any resentment.
I put myself in that position.
I was responsible for it.
I paid a price.
By the way,
I've got rich off to some show.
Just can't help but be crazy.
You know,
it's very unfortunate.
And when you're talking about a girl who's a,
you know,
exotic dancer,
La probably on drugs,
I mean a good person or she had a 12 year old daughter that that was,
she went,
wow,
I got this chance to be with this guy who could be a star.
And I just screwed that up.
Uh,
and I might've just screwed that up and,
and uh,
you know,
I've got to silence my phone.
I'm sorry.
I thought I did.
Um,
so I just never,
uh,
and we reconcile me and the guy runs out when he found out the truth and it was
fine.
Yeah.
I saw him like right after it happened.
I know.
Thank God.
What a mess.
The whole thing,
which is such a mess in a bad situation.
I felt,
I felt almost a little bit guilty that I had left her alone with you.
Yeah.
Cause I,
I,
you know,
I knew that creeped out.
Yeah.
I was long ass time ago.
You were really creeped out and I was like,
you're going to be right.
Yeah,
mark.
Okay,
fine.
Right.
And so I left remember that so well I remember you saying I have and I go,
I go just drive,
drive with us,
you know,
and you're like,
I can't do that.
I'm going home.
I remember that so well.
Yeah,
I just remember the one,
it was all going down like when we were at the club level,
like this is nothing but trouble.
It's this is a track mare.
Like what?
It's going.
First of all,
she wasn't even attractive.
Okay.
No she was not.
I mean I'm not bullshitting.
She was an unattractive girl.
She did not have a good body.
She did not have a good face.
And if you were going to go get dances,
there was a bunch of really attractive girls there and you probably would have
picked someone else if that's what you were there for.
So it was like she worked you for money anyway because you got in there and she
climbed on top of like she did.
She did.
She did work cause she,
she,
she kept saying,
you want another dance and you kept peeling off money.
I remember,
oh,
remember I told you to sit next to me so it didn't
look like [inaudible],
dude,
you got to sit next to me cause I,
I don't want,
you know,
she's dancing on me the whole time.
Listen,
God,
you would dance from another girl to get her off your lap.
I paid a pretty girl to go over and dance with him.
But when you're with now,
now as you get older,
the,
you know what you do,
you get up and leave or you don't go there in the first place.
But when you're young,
we're such idiots.
We were such idiots.
But we were retarded,
but sane enough to know that this was a giant monster problem.
Yeah.
That was just one step along the way of me realizing like that,
like crazy girls aren't really fun.
I used to think crazy.
I remember me,
dude,
I was the king of that to no one,
no one,
Joe Smith,
Joe would sniff it out so fast.
He'd go,
he,
I'd be in this girl and I mean dating her.
He goes,
she's crazy.
I go,
no,
no.
She's a good girl.
No dude,
she's crazy.
You need to run now.
Nah,
I'm not going to listen to Joe.
Six months later pregnant.
What?
My House,
I've got a,
uh,
an unusual ability to spot people who are off.
There's a smell that they have.
There's a way that they communicate with me.
I don't know what it is.
Maybe it's because I'm a little aggressive and even though I'm really nice and
friendly,
there's something about me that just puts people on a little bit of an edge.
Say it looked like it could be a Douche bag.
You saved me because of that.
But because of that,
like,
because I have this weird thing about me,
sometimes people get a little uneasy and when people get a little uneasy just
for a second,
they reveal who they really are.
They just,
there's just something about people when they know you're looking at them,
they know you're paying attention to them.
It's like when you're going on stage and you're bombing on stage,
you know that,
that hyper sensitive feeling that you have of being judged and watched and
you're,
you're falling short.
Well,
when people are crazy and you look at them funny,
you know,
and you and you try it,
they'll just show it to you.
That's very just like,
I'm crazy.
Sometimes it to me,
I may creeps me out like,
all right,
this guy's gonna rate me.
He's [inaudible].
You know,
it's not [inaudible] on snap crazy
people.
You have to allow them to pretend that they're normal.
You have to allow them,
you give them time,
you know,
you let them,
you have a conversation with them.
Things get rolling and you go,
well,
I'm just going to let this guy get away with this.
All Right Bob.
Well,
very nice meeting you and joy indeed.
You know,
and you know,
but if you don't do that,
if you're like,
why you talking to me like that?
Like what's going on here?
Are you,
are you crazy?
Like what's going on here?
Right.
But if you expose that right away,
then all that crazy juice comes flying out of them because you've always been so
good at that,
man.
You nailed his,
how many?
I nailed one.
Would you say?
[inaudible].
Yeah,
you saved my life though with that.
I got,
I was going to get married because somebody got pregnant and you literally were
on the phone going,
I'm losing you man.
I'm losing you.
You're,
you're,
you're talking yourself into it.
I know you.
This is not the girl you wanna spend the rest of your life with you.
I'm losing you.
I'm an eye and I compared it to patty because his ex girlfriends was like super
cool,
super intelligent,
like really fun to be around.
And this girl was just,
does Zombie a mess?
It was just,
it was all bad energy and fucking just,
Oh,
that end.
And then he was like telling me that this is ed.
He's going to settle down.
I'm like,
whoa.
You know how many kid is one thing that's not in your control but you cannot
fucking marry this chick,
but you should run away from her a long time ago.
And she was the best thing.
Best thing I ever did.
I was around so many of them.
I got to smell them.
I got to know what the hell.
Come on,
man.
It's the one place I never got used to.
I was going to say I lived overseas.
The point of that was I never,
I,
I can get used to anything.
La is the one place actually never really got used to because you ran into so
many crazy people.
Yeah.
And people who live in the rest of the country,
I don't think you really can understand how nutty it is.
Just think of this place and there's this place where everyone gravitates to
that has a deficit,
like really needs an incredible amount of attention.
And we're both guilty of it,
you know?
I mean,
look,
there's only one way you become a comedian.
You have to have a fucked up childhood where you're not loved enough.
It's just this fact,
you know,
my freaks,
my mom out and I want to say that and it's not her.
And you know,
she did her best,
but my parents were divorced and you know,
I don't know my dad and there's just,
and you've got your issues and I've got my issues.
And all actors have their issues,
all of them to hold.
No other reason.
And there's a few people like you know,
it was cool that dude from Vegas,
Josh do is and he's a good guy.
I worked in coolest shit like regular down to earth.
There's a bunch of it like that Mario Lopez is like that.
Just regular normal down there do very cool.
But most people know,
most people are,
they have this giant hole and that's how they've made it to the top of the heap
because their whole is so needy that to just stuffing things into to it all the
time to try to stay famous.
Yeah.
I mean it's just,
it's a mad sickness and an obsession.
And here's this one place on the,
on the map where everyone gravitates to,
to try to be the next,
that guy they want to be Tom cruise or you know any and there's the,
they outnumber everyone else.
And even if you get like out here where I live,
like out deep into the burbs,
you,
you find them like the ones that have given up,
you know,
they all have aspirations.
You know,
there's wives down the street here.
They want to be on the real housewives of,
of fucking Calabasas or some shit.
You know,
I mean there's,
there's,
there's all of them.
They wanted to be a singer.
It didn't work out.
There's so many of them.
It's like my buddy was like,
my buddy was like,
why does my dentist have a screenplay
or a headshot,
a headshot.
Really,
Jesus,
you dig a little bit and you find out everybody came out here and that's why you
sit through traffic and how many people try to get you to read their shit and
how,
and we just had a situation.
Well,
dude,
I've had so many situations,
but guys who tried to get me to produce their shit,
like I have this,
uh,
this idea,
I just want to produce a pilot.
Do you think you can help me?
Like what are you talking about man?
I deal with it every single day.
Everybody favors,
everyone has favors too.
They're like,
I need help.
Can you fill this out dish for me or do this for that?
Can you help me get in the comedy?
And Magic Club.
I don't even know you do.
Can I open for you on the road?
It's like it's,
it's constant and and needy.
[inaudible]
did you ever email someone and ask them if you can open for them?
No.
Especially when you were an open Mike or I've had like open miker is that asked,
this is one kid who from England and he sends me this thing.
He says he's like one of the youngest headliners ever in England and he wants to
a co headline with me,
you know,
next time I do a gig up there and he's worked with this guy and that guy is
coming to America soon.
I'm like,
what the fuck are you talking?
I need you.
Yeah.
You know what?
That's exactly what my show is missing.
I need a co headline.
Those headlines or she would just side that you would attach yourself to someone
else's show because I couldn't even imagine thinking like that.
Like if someone was playing in town,
like say if when I was first starting out of,
you know,
Bill Hicks was coming into town,
would that last one when I was an open Miker,
you know,
the idea that would call up,
hey,
can I get seven minutes on Bill Hicks or should look like what?
Well,
I think it's a question that a lot of kids need that constant need and they
don't understand.
You've got to earn things and it takes time,
you know?
Yeah.
Well there's plenty of places to get on stage.
The time to get on stages,
not during a professional show and storing all those bringer shows and you know,
and then you eventually put together an act and then people put you on your show
because they want you on the show.
You don't,
you don't go like,
so listening for it on,
on other people's shows is also one of the strange things like acting,
but especially stand up where,
you know,
if you can be an actor,
it's like you can,
you can be an actor and get away with it sometimes.
Like you can,
you can be a good look in 22 year old and get a show and actually make a lot of
money for five years.
And then that parlays no another show.
And before you know it,
you've got like a big house and millions of dollars because you know,
if you're,
if somewhat emotionally available and you know,
but um,
uh,
stand up is one thing you cannot fake and don't tell me you want to get into it
when you're 38,
it's just going to be a waste of your time.
You're not going to be willing to do the things that you have to do in order to
get good at it.
You have to,
you have to live it and you have to be there every night.
You have to perform everywhere.
You've got to do coffee shops and shit holes and dive bars.
Only way in is through and,
and you know,
it's also a rhythm.
Like I,
I'd never tried,
I never take,
like people asked me,
how come I,
I perform every week?
Well,
because if I take too much time off,
I lose my rhythm.
Yeah.
Like,
it's,
it's like a song in a way,
you know,
and you,
if you're not thinking about it,
you're not writing new stuff either.
You gotta come,
you gotta constantly be,
it's constantly alive.
You have to keep it alive.
If I don't perform every week,
like I'll go sometimes where I'll take a couple of weeks off and then I do a
show.
I always feel,
I always feel like a little off,
but then when you do like a weekend,
a long weekend,
somewhere like Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
you know,
by the time Sunday rolls around,
you're just a juggernaut.
Yeah.
I liken it to sort of,
um,
I was in Canada and it was a Sunday.
I had one of the best shows I've ever had and I,
I like into it.
I cut this feeling,
I got this kind of like,
like a kind of,
I felt like,
uh,
this warm kind of cloudy feeling and I knew I didn't have to really do anything.
Like everything kind of took over.
I feel that way.
Right?
Yeah.
You're writing it.
I'm coming up with jokes.
They,
they're coming to me on stage.
It's like that flow that it's the greatest feeling,
that wax will that tuning in to.
I mean that's really channeling,
right?
It's like you're channeling,
I always say that,
and I described this on stage this way,
that when I'm at my best,
it's like I'm a passenger.
It's like I'm riding it.
And did you,
did you,
there's a great story about this.
The who won the fields,
medal
and mathematics.
He was that guy.
He,
he figured out a math equation they'd been trying to figure out since 1806 and
the answer was 357 pages long or something like that.
Gives you an idea.
So he went to the metal and mathematics,
which is,
which is worth $1 million and it's the Nobel prize for math.
Basically it's the fields medal,
right?
It's the most prestigious thing.
So this genius,
he's the Siberian guy.
If aliens heard about this guy,
he doesn't take the money.
Yeah.
He just said,
boy,
he disappeared.
He went and they found them in his and his aunts,
like Shaq fishing shack like a year later.
And they were like,
you know,
BBC was like,
look you,
you won this,
this,
you know,
fields metal.
Why didn't you take it?
And he said,
well,
you guys are worshiping the wrong thing.
You should be worshiping.
It's like worshiping the radio,
the receiver instead of the actual music.
He goes,
the answer is always been in the template in the sky.
I just happen to have a certain frequency and wiring that was able to channel it
through my body.
Don't,
don't,
don't worship me for being wired a certain way.
I just channeled it,
will show the actual equation.
I went,
you know what that said?
Great way of looking at everything.
That's all it was.
A lot of artists believe,
you know,
a lot of people call it the Muse and they've called it that for thousands of
years.
That,
you know,
something comes to you and gives you these ideas.
You know,
like the story you're gonna write already exist in the war of art.
Is that Pressfield,
Steven Pressfield,
Pressfield book,
great book for creative people who are into,
you know,
uh,
like something that gives you like inspiration to write and work.
It's a really good,
it's called the war for art.
And he talks more of our talks about,
talk about,
he talks about resistance and how it,
this constant,
but if you keep showing up enough fatal,
the gods will kind of reveal in pieces your story.
Yes.
And he talks very openly about the idea that,
you know,
a muse comes to him and Steven King,
I've,
I've heard him say something very similar as well.
And I always say that I feel like when,
when my ideas come to me,
when they come to me,
it's when I'm empty,
when I'm empty and then they just filing in and I'm just sort of sorting them
out along the way when they come to me on stage.
Like I've had bits come to me on stage full bits and like just comes to me.
Like it might be two or three minutes long and I'll keep going on it.
And it's crazy.
It's like inside of the sky,
you know?
Weird,
isn't it?
Yeah.
I allow myself to,
for that to happen on purpose.
I put myself in tricky situations.
I'll put myself like,
well,
I'll start talking about something where I don't have any a bit on it.
I don't even know what I'm gonna say.
And I'll put myself in that situation,
show that like I'm on my hyper comedy mode cause I'm onstage.
And there's pressure because people are watching and sometimes you know,
sometimes it works and sometimes it doesn't.
If it doesn't,
then it just seems like I'm talking about nonsense for like a minute.
And then I had passion quickly as something that I know is going to be funny,
get back.
But every now and then you'll go down a road and then,
oh look,
I found a bag of gold.
And there's just,
yeah.
And you know,
you almost can't,
can't take credit for that.
No,
you can't.
Musicians talk about it like a jazz musicians call it swinging and when they're
out on that limb and they're swinging,
they gotta find their way back in a thematic way.
That comes back to the original tune they were playing and that that's,
that's what Milton went.
Marcel photo that exists in Jujitsu that exists in,
in even in playing pool,
there's a thing in playing pool,
you call where you are in dead stroke when you're in dead stroke.
It's like your arm is tuned into the stick,
which is tuned into the ball,
which is tuned into the cloth.
You know exactly how hard you have to hit the ball to move it in a certain
position.
You know exactly what kind of spin in English and it's all just automatic.
You don't even have to think,
you can't miss stuff,
I think.
I think that's what I really,
what drives me in art or whatever you call the tonight's show up.
You know,
it's like it.
Flannery O'connor is great writer in the 30s died of ms whatever,
and she,
she said,
I sit at my typewriter every morning at six 30 not to write,
but in case something happens.
So it's an act of faith,
you know?
Well,
that's the Pressfield argument that he believes that you show up and that the
muse will,
will greet you,
that you put in the discipline and it will reward you.
You need to put it in the discipline.
The gods have to see that you are worthy.
But he's the company offers guy that I've ever heard address resistance and the
resistance to write,
which I have very badly.
And I think everyone created all does.
We all do.
It's like getting into cold water,
you know,
like,
it's like,
uh,
when you,
when you're just,
you just like,
I got to get in this cohort.
I know my body is going to acclimate and once you start flowing,
you're flowing.
But right.
I the things I find to do everyday rather than,
right.
Like I cleaned the dishes.
I'll be,
I'll make every phone call,
I can,
I'll read articles on the web that have nothing to do with anything off.
I'll find incredible websites.
I'll beat off,
forget it.
The problem with the Internet is that it's right there on your computer.
And so when you're supposed to be writing,
I have this awesome program.
It's called Wright Room.
Check this out and it,
I have it for the Mac,
but when you click on it and it opens up you a,
you lose everything on your desktop.
So that like that.
So it's just green,
green print that's collect background.
It's awesome.
And uh,
that's how I write now because I'm such a monkey,
I can't allow myself any,
any possible distractions.
I'm just too stupid here.
You're in good company.
So I,
but why is it that so many creative people are like that?
I mean,
why is it if you love the idea of creating and I do,
I love,
I love writing blogs.
I love putting them up and getting feedback.
I love the people,
enjoy them and I'm loving writing this book.
I love it.
Like last night I wrote a bunch of good shit that I really enjoyed and it's so,
such a good feeling to go to and I go to bed like all energized,
like I feel like,
wow,
I did some good shit.
Like,
but why is it that like the,
the next day I will a watch,
you know,
15 youtube videos on the 2011 Shelby Mustang,
and for 45 minutes,
550 horsepower,
man,
look at that aluminum block,
that things to shit.
It's a modern muscle car.
I mean,
I don't get any size if I leave and I go to bed when I do that feeling the
stress.
Cause you haven't done your work.
Exactly.
I,
I shouldn't be,
you know,
like really pretend that I'm not disciplined because I'm pretty destructive.
I get a lot of shit done,
but not as much as I could.
No,
I think um,
Adderall I think does that the key,
that's what you need.
I don't need that shit.
I know someone who's on that and he got no pills going to take you away from the
human condition.
And the responsibility of,
of,
of actually what
I think is neat about art is like creating things.
Usually you're,
you're,
you're creating something out of nothing but,
but,
but not that.
It's not connected to other things and other experiences,
but,
but you're trying to create something out of nothing.
But the other issue is that I find writing and you know,
as you find your voice and whatever you're doing,
you're actually getting down and distilling who you really are.
You get down to the core of who you really are.
And it's way easier in life to pretend man ways you're in life,
to be a character.
It just is.
I spent so much time as a kid building armor around myself because the world was
a dangerous place.
And,
and that really wasn't where my strength lay.
You know,
most of us are there.
There's a saying that I had a teacher,
an old teacher used to say,
in order to be all you can be,
you've got to face up to who you're pretending to be.
Uh,
and it really,
I think most of us are walking around man playing a character and not really
even,
do you ever listen to conversations with people?
End Up exposes that,
but acting does not.
No,
it doesn't.
Acting reinforces that those,
those shields to get thicker and deeper.
Probably.
I do think that like someone like Daniel Day Lewis might be gay.
He said something interesting.
He was like,
why are you guys so interested in my process?
I show up on a set having thoughts that don't belong to me.
And,
and,
and talking like that,
like awake and he goes in,
you know why I'm an actor?
They go,
why they,
if it was like,
why,
why?
He goes,
because I'm essentially ashamed of being a boring Middleclass Englishman.
I do love boring life,
so I have to pretend it was so great,
but he does in some way tap into a real act.
Yeah.
And he taps into a truth within them.
I think.
Like he,
he likes to find that character within him that actually exists.
Maybe it's a past life.
Well,
I think what he's really good at it.
He's really good at becoming another human being,
you know?
And that's,
there's a real art in that,
you know,
you have to assume it's not judging that other human being.
That's what the art is,
I think,
you know,
becoming them.
Yeah.
Like when you play like a Robert Duvall was playing Stalin and I think he said,
um,
he said,
well,
I'm,
um,
how do you play a monster?
And he says,
he's not a monster.
And they said,
what are you killed?
40 million people?
He goes,
yeah,
but the actual can't think that.
And they said,
well,
what'd you do?
And he said,
I played a man trying to solve a problem.
And if that problem was too many people in the Ural Mountains,
well,
I've got to get rid of them.
I'm just trying to industrialize the Soviet Union.
Our problem is we're in the 18 hundreds.
I got to industrial,
which means I've got to move entire swaths of people over there.
And by the way,
if you're in my way,
I got it.
I got to kill you.
It's just easier.
And it was really interesting.
He said that that's,
that's,
that's the way you,
you can't judge the person that you're playing those actors.
That's a different breed.
That's a complete breed.
Apart from what we're talking about.
We shouldn't even be calling them actors because they just happened to choose
acting.
The nutty people,
or we should call them just energy holes,
you know,
whether they're actors or singers or could,
they could be comic book artists or whatever the fuck they are.
There's just those people that need,
they just need attention.
There's a big difference between that and like say a somebody trying to say
something.
Yeah.
Gary Oldman.
There's an artist.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a guy.
He becomes different human beings.
There's a real craft to it would probably doing it regardless of money or are
they driven by,
it's driven by,
by kind of mining the psyches of the human mind,
the human psyche and driven by,
you know,
just producing this really perfect character and heroin and driven by a little
bit honest.
Is He,
from what I understand,
he,
he likes it.
He likes his drugs.
Uh,
I guess he's better now.
It's amazing how much good music has come from heroin.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people that were in heroin though.
You know what though?
There's,
there's,
there's a counter argument to that and that is this,
that Nick [inaudible],
who is a rock journalist in the,
in the 60s wrote a book called the dark stuff.
And a lot of people would say that what was really,
really well there was this,
this explosion in music and,
and with the Monterey,
I'm a music festival and things like that where,
where the drug of choice at the time was weed.
And,
um,
I'm a little,
a little a psychedelic,
hold on one second.
Key Up.
Find it online.
Voodoo child,
slight return.
Oh,
it's such a great Jimi Hendrix is,
if I had to choose like one music to listen to for the rest of my life,
only one,
it would be Jimi Hendrix songs.
And you'd be right there.
I'm,
I'm there with Zeplin too was a rabbit heroin user.
Yeah.
He connected to the fucking,
the,
the vibrations of the universe.
Here's what,
this is what,
here's what they find,
what they believe killed that music movement,
yet this incredible successful music.
What was was heroin?
Cocaine.
It's because it,
yeah.
And so what you had was a bunch of musicians in the 60s who's heroes were who
the black blues musicians and Stanley crouch wrote this really cool.
I say that said that what happened was guys like Janis Joplin,
Jim Morrison,
Jimi Hendrix,
et Cetera,
who died all coincidentally at 27 was that they're heroes with these blues
musicians who are doing drugs,
right?
They,
they,
they wanted to be like their,
their heroes.
They were subscribing.
They were subscribing to an addiction as opposed to overcoming something.
Whereas the black musicians who had to come in through the back door and play
for a wide audience and eat a hotdog and a warm cup of coffee,
they basically felt guilty as like survivor guilt.
They were making all this money in their wish,
but they couldn't even play at other black people and they were living in a
segregated society.
So a lot of them went into drugs as a way of dealing with that guilt.
Whereas you have,
you had these white sixties musicians who were like,
my hero did drugs.
I'm going to do drugs because that's part of being a rock and roller problem is
when you choose heroin is your drug and said a weed,
you're going to have a hard time staying awake to write good music.
That is true.
Like what?
What gives you this inspiration?
What connects you to the universe?
Utterly destroys your body and makes you a prisoner,
but like cute to the beginning of this hit to hit the very beginning.
There's,
there's something about the music from the fucking sixties especially like this
kind of Hendricks.
Do you know whether something so universal about it?
It just lasts.
Whereas I believe they were trying to say something for real and change the
world.
They were idealists to believe that they could.
That's what,
because everybody was high.
We live in a cynical time now.
Nothing,
nothing changes.
Anything.
Right?
Listen to this man.
There had been nothing remotely like this.
There's no one had done anything like this with a guitar before that you heard
anything even remotely like this?
There's one to this one guy that comes close.
He's a monster as me.
Yeah,
Dude.
It's just like,
this music is so good.
It lasts for so long.
It's still,
it's still on inspiring now 40 years later.
The layers to it,
and this is all psychedelic inspired,
you know,
it's all a bunch of different drugs and those drugs also 10,000 hours of
practice.
Yes.
It's that too.
It's,
it's the,
the,
the practice makes the discipline in the practice makes the human being the very
best antenna to tune in the magic of the universe and when you dissolve the ego
completely,
like when you do a lot of psychedelics and you're an artist like Jimi Hendrix,
you crushed that thing to the point where you just,
you're so open when you're on stage.
The music,
you know,
is doing something with a guitar in today's world who I think is unbelievable as
Jack White.
Yeah.
From the white stripes.
I don't know them how he loved them.
He was a mom.
I know a bunch of their songs that I've heard that I really enjoy,
but I don't know enough about him.
Live note note.
No,
he never plays the same song twice.
It's
the same way as really he's a true,
I mean,
if you hear him,
you ever hear that Song Jolene screaming it totally.
Or,
or uh,
that other song he does stuff on a guitar that's Whoa,
lean.
Yeah.
Dolly Parton,
Dolly Parton.
What the fuck that is?
I mean,
it's riveting.
This is the beautiful thing about what we got going on here.
Do we got computers just like almost like a real radio show man.
But you know,
it's,
it's sad that,
you know,
the,
these,
all these different greats that got into heroin all wound up dying,
you know,
really fucked up.
Dense.
Janis Joplin,
Hendrix,
I mean,
so many great musicians.
What it did was,
what it did was it kind of had robbed us of what else they were going to be
capable of doing.
Right.
But is the argument that it would have never,
they would've never been who they were without the drugs.
And even though the drugs rob them,
it's almost like the amount of energy.
I mean,
this is,
it's a shitty argument,
but just for the sake of saying it,
like,
think about what Jimmy Hendrix has done and the,
the amount of impact that he had in such a short life.
I mean,
I think,
what,
how was he 28 or something when he died?
Uh,
he was a 37,
27.
So think about the amount,
the,
the impact that that guy had in his short time on the surf.
Let me hold on to this.
Uh,
listen to this song.
We'll hold on.
Sorry.
Think about the impact that this guy had in his short time on earth in the short
time where he was completely drugged out of his fucking head.
Right?
It's like this accelerated burst of creativity.
It's almost like he used up all of his energy in one big explosion,
you know?
Well,
is,
is that the case or did he already come to the table before he started doing
drugs?
Prodigiously talented,
potentially technical on the guitar and then,
and then slowly eroded that talent.
That's other question.
So there's a good possibility of that.
It's definitely,
I think it's,
it's both.
It's the wrong song.
Yeah,
no,
I'll find it.
It's uh,
these motherfuckers.
What kind of a radio show or we run in here.
Ladies and gentlemen,
if you are in your car right now,
if you were at the gym,
if you are on the train on the way to work,
listen to him.
I apologize for the unprofessional behavior.
Here we go.
Is
Maybe worse recording of all times.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm glad you guys are just one click.
Oh,
we'll find it.
This name shouting.
This is Jack White and he's singing Jolene.
Yeah.
And this is a Dolly Parton songs that made me cry when I was 18,
which I believe is about her pleading with her own addiction,
which is Jolene.
Don't take my man away.
Wow.
I really compete with you.
What was her addiction?
Uh,
not,
this was writing for somebody who's,
who is in the deck
when did that,
okay.
We don't need this part.
This is dumb.
No,
we're here.
So that's the worst banter ever.
Dude's talking to the audience in between songs.
I've got an awesome one though with Paul Stanley.
It's a compilation that some dude in the New York did all Paul Stanley's
cheesiest lines ever talking to the audience.
Yeah,
I got to hear.
That's fantastic.
[inaudible]
got it to him.
[inaudible] okay,
dude,
that's,
that's a talented motherfucker.
He's unbelievable.
He filled the whole kind of for me,
uh,
that,
that when Kurt Cobain died,
he kind of replaced my Kurt Cobain for me.
Really?
Yeah.
I know.
I need,
I need to pay attention more to them.
I to,
he's a total innovator and it's a two man band.
What is it about someone singing a really bad ass song to just really gives you
a burst in your body?
It might be,
it might be.
It might be.
Honestly,
to me,
the most powerful art form and for that reason,
yeah.
You literally feel inspiration and energy.
Yeah.
It,
this woman,
Karen Armstrong wrote a book called the case for God and she was,
it was a,
it was like,
she was like,
you know people,
well,
you have atheist who talk,
they look at a fundamentalist concept of God.
And she said,
look.
She goes,
wow,
God is not something you're supposed to be able to explain.
But I can tell you when you listen to an incredible music of sounds like an
incredible piece of music that's Britain PR that's profoundly sad yet fills you
with,
with an inexplicable joy or,
or,
or tense energy or quickening energy.
Um,
that inspiration is every bit as real as what you can touch in front of you.
That that is maybe more real in what we stay alive for.
And that is,
she gives,
she gives sort of a,
she correlates that with the,
the,
with the divine or the concept of a god or this benevolent insane good that we
can't really actually measure or categorize.
And it's kind of a cool some,
what music is,
is like an energy source that we create an emotional energy source.
And if you,
if you put the words right in the music right,
and the right person delivering it with the right amount of honesty,
it just taps into the,
the,
the very like the just the fiber of your being or something.
It just charges you,
well,
it's called harmony.
You know,
the Greeks describe beauty in one word.
Socrates said,
how do you describe beauty?
And Aristotle and Socrates,
they,
they always used one word that harmony.
So when you see a cheetah running,
you say,
that's beautiful.
The reason you see it,
you say it's beautiful.
It's because its body is working in such harmonious like,
um,
uh,
it's such lockstep with itself.
That's why I call fights beautiful.
Whenever like,
no doubt,
Mash guys,
I'm always the,
I always say,
look at this beautiful combination and why Kelly ends with this kick to the body
and he'd see his whole body cave in this beauty,
in that man,
man fighting to me like I,
the reason I love watching,
fighting and I always love to fight when I was coming up and young and stuff was
that,
to me it is,
it is one of the purest things,
uh,
someone can endeavor to do because when you fight,
like on the level of guys like Nate,
Mark Core,
Anderson Silva,
it requires all of you all acquires,
you're cutting,
your courage,
your strength,
your flexibility.
People say,
oh,
he's a horseback ride.
Or you use every muscle in your body.
You don't know what you're talking about.
Getting a ring and all around,
Bro,
that's a different muscle.
You don't even have to spar anybody.
Go Punch the bag for three minutes.
But also if you're going to go of somebody trying to kick you and punch in the
head,
you may not come out the same.
You May,
you may be dead or you may be massive,
massive emotional charge connected to your performance.
You're literally fighting over.
You're very health.
You're very health longterm,
not just tonight.
That's right.
You know,
if you find a really scary dude,
you know you fight an Anderson Silva,
you have to think that guy's going to change your brain.
Well,
I might head kick you and change your brain.
It also faces every man.
I believe every man,
his biggest fear is that he's a coward.
Like if you ask every man's biggest aspirations as he wants is to be a hero.
And as big as fear is that he finds himself out to be a coward.
And when you fight and you put yourself into a ring where somebody might kick
and punch you,
you face up to that and it's why I have so much respect for fighters.
I've always found them to be.
I've always found fighting to be.
When I watch a really great fight,
I cry sometimes because I find it's so dramatic and glorious,
like the pants on.
I never wear my pants.
I always wear a testicle essential though to keep myself discipline to
testicles.
It's made of hemp rope.
I can't go into it right now,
but I sell them on my website,
which is your website,
Brian cowen.com.
Brian Killen docs know why I don't really cry,
but it just sounds good for chicks,
but sounds awesome.
Do you Twitter a lot?
Do you check your Twitter first time I went to Brian's house,
first time ever Brian had a,
what is it to kill a mockingbird sitting there on his,
uh,
his coffee table or something,
something like probably say,
oh no,
we don't have all the books out.
Yeah.
What was,
what was the,
who was supposed to kill a mockingbird?
I had,
I had Shakespeare.
Jack Kerouac was out and so I came over to his house and the fruit.
I just immediately started giving them shit.
I like,
what the fuck are you doing,
but you ain't reading these things.
I go,
you throw these down for when chicks come over.
You look like all deep and Shit.
I called Jimmy Burke.
I was like,
dude,
I'm a hoax.
I'm laying books around my room.
There's one girl I liked and she was like,
she had gotten a Harvard and I'm literally throwing books out.
I didn't like Babette's feast.
I don't even know what I was like,
Bat,
bat speed.
I've,
I've never read this book.
I hadn't read any of them.
That's hilarious.
Sorry,
I'm a man of letters.
When I met Brian,
he didn't have a lock or a front door knob.
He lived,
he lived in a fucking apartment.
It was on television.
Okay.
He lived in an apartment.
It just had a whole,
and I go,
what happened?
I was fucking girl came over and things got crazy.
Whatever.
Where did you live in Venice?
Venice is fucking dangerous.
On the beach.
He had an apartment on the beach,
which was awesome by the way,
which is the first time I'd ever known anybody who actually lived on the beach.
Like you left his apartment like you opened a window.
There's the ocean's right there.
Like you would go leave his apartment and you just walk right out onto the
beach.
It was fucking,
it was uncredible.
You want to come over to my house?
I've got a puppy in the view of the beach.
You want to,
I don't know what you're doing.
Anything right now.
I'm on TV.
Yeah,
I was 28 years old.
Do you think I got laid am on TV?
I've got a puppy and a view of the beach.
You want to come meet you live there.
What made you love about girls?
Girls.
That's what the beach,
the beach front calculate.
Well,
why you think I'm going to act well?
What do you tell?
What kind of question is that?
So you became an actor just for chicks.
If you want to get serious with me now.
I never want to embarrass me and why?
Fine.
Let's get that.
You want to be,
you want to get you and we end the truth here.
Yeah.
That's why I did everything.
I literally started learning how to fight so that I didn't have to be in a bar
with somebody like hit on my girl.
I had to walk away bad in front of her.
I was like at least like your own safety.
Just worried about cutting down.
You're pushing,
right.
At least I look at least I don't look like a coward even though I am.
At least I can fake it and keep the guy busy for awhile and get laid.
Hopefully later on.
Do you bust out the,
Hey,
I was in sex in the city.
That's cool.
What do I have my real on me,
you know,
out of the loop when they come into my house,
I'm playing it on your iPhone should have a keyed up on youtube.
One thing on again,
this is crazy.
You know,
a lot of people recognize me from sex and the city,
but they really recognize me from being an original cast member on mad TV.
The hangover to somebody just recognize me.
I'll recognize myself sometimes.
The Mad TV thing was such a strange thing,
man.
You want to do it?
How many seasons to seasons?
You got lucky you escaped.
That was the weirdest environment ever for like a talk show.
Yeah,
it was very weird.
There was a lot of like weird competition and there was a lot of like weird
energy there.
Yeah man,
it was a,
it was a rough place.
You didn't like it.
Right?
It was cool that I got to meet already.
Lying there too.
Yeah,
I didn't like it.
I loved rd.
How fucking great is that guy?
He's great.
And how sad is his whole situation man?
I think he uh,
yeah,
I think Ardi just uh,
has always struggled with those demons.
You don't know.
He attempted suicide and stabbed himself and stab themselves up a bunch of
times.
Funniest Guy,
by the way,
for me,
probably the funniest guy off the cuff,
like the most improvisational funny guys I've ever met.
He used this and a beautiful person.
Yeah,
he's a great guy.
Always,
always enjoyed running into him,
you know?
And uh,
it made me really sad when I would listen to them on the stern show and I'd
hero,
he's falling apart.
It's just very depressing.
Yeah,
no,
the very depressing.
You see that big,
you know,
seeing him not take care of himself and get that big,
yeah,
I guess I don't know what his condition is.
Do we know that's kind of,
no,
I don't know.
I have no idea.
Have no information.
It's kind of a weird situation,
man.
When you're,
you become that big fat guy that everybody loves because people love big fat
guys that don't give a fuck,
you know?
And also what happens if you lose weight?
Does that mean to be funny anymore?
And Persona goes away?
She always lost a hundred pounds.
Jody has lost a hundred pounds and he's funnier than ever.
He's still a fat guy.
Joey DA's.
Not Joey Diaz is just,
he's such a character.
He's so great.
One of the greatest human beings I've ever met.
One of the coolest,
most interesting fines ever as far as like people to hang out with.
You know what man?
He's a guy.
Joey Diaz is the guy who so colorful and so I see somebody,
but we'll have these friends and you end up hanging out with a guy and you're
not laughing.
Once you hang around,
Joey Diaz get constantly and you,
you're just stare at him and listen to his amazing stories.
Our friend Eddie Bravo had a,
a wristband on once.
It was a leather wristband that he was wearing,
you know,
rock and roll,
man transformation.
And uh,
he,
uh,
had this leather wristband on show.
He looks into,
goes,
what are you waiting for?
A fucking Falcon,
the land on your arm.
And he got so pissed off.
He was really upset.
I always,
Eddie,
Eddie Bravo is good.
It's fucking build a Jujitsu empire.
Every time I see this bridge spans,
I am always like,
oh,
that's cool.
What are you wearing?
A fucking fall down.
That echoes I head.
That's one of my jokes.
I always talk about if you're gonna wear a Cape,
you gotta have a Falcon and not a penguin.
Cause that's true success rate.
Yeah,
I'd love to.
I didn't even get laid in 2010 with a Cape and totally fall apart.
Well,
it was the last time someone could rock a Cape and not look stupid.
I've made a comeback.
I don't know if you know,
if you're the pope and you can bless a billion people like this,
you can wear a cape.
Other than that,
I may be Johnny Depp and get away to go out of style and the must've hundreds,
hundreds along with the coach and buggy.
Okay.
And those crazy blonde wigs.
Yeah,
dude,
because you can't wear a cape and a Cape is very handy.
You can doubles as a rap if there's like a bee swarm.
People like base by water can just be like whatever.
And just,
you know,
they're not going to sting a red tent.
Fuck you bs.
It's a Mexican fear factor.
It was a,
uh,
they made their own stunts,
like really dangerous low budget.
And there was a Mexican host and the Mexican guy wore a cape.
Really?
Yeah.
There was one that I saw at,
well,
I don't know if you were a in every episode,
but a Mormon one that I saw,
that guy was wearing a cape and uh,
he was,
uh,
he had these people go through this burning building and we did the exact same
stunt,
but when we did it,
they had fire suits on and helmets and shit.
And we had people waiting with hoses and people on standby,
but we let this fucking building on fire and they had to go in and rescue this
dummy and bring it out.
It's very difficult and hard to see.
They didn't shorts.
They re they reproduce.
They think people would fucking shorts.
They were getting third degree burns and shit running through fire with shorts
on,
you know,
they're not snow.
Mexico doesn't give a fuck.
Do I give a shit?
They don't give a toff.
Even the boxers,
like by the time the children eat those down,
they closed down a big part of a Arizona,
the national park in Arizona because it's too much,
too much Mexican gang member violence from the drug cartels.
It's bleeding over in Arizona.
Mexicans are very,
very much like when you watch the boxing style,
they'll stand in a hole and just bang it out.
There's no like moving out of the way,
just like,
let's take the,
let's take the punishment and p and c,
you can punch you shorter.
They enjoy fisticuffs and balls,
but I mean like guys like Chavez,
even though he took a lot of shots,
he was very hard.
Yeah.
He was very elusive for a guy that would stay on top of him saying like,
I got like Mayweather's always staying out of the way.
It's just the whole deal.
Before I even learned how to fight Mayweather is the most cautious of all the
boxers,
even when he hurts the guy and doesn't pour it on what would have happened with
him in that pack.
Yeah.
Who knows?
It's a fascinating fight and I think a lot of people want to see it.
It's a dangerous fight for him,
for,
uh,
for me,
whether it's dangerous.
That's why you think he was saying,
but pack,
y'all could get fucked up too,
man.
Mayweather's awesome.
And May was a boxer and he's so sharp.
His technique is so good.
He has a such a deep knowledge of boxing.
He's also bigger than packet.
Yeah.
He's,
he's bigger.
His keys technique might be a little cleaner,
a little less fat to it.
He's,
he's a very smart guy to Pacquiao though.
It was a wild man,
dude.
If you look at like his knockout of Ricky Hatton,
the way took apart,
dude,
he's a monster.
That little dude is so fast.
His technique is so good too.
He's just,
you know,
apparently with Cota when he was a,
I was at that fight and I was pretty close to the ring and w w um,
I didn't hear this,
but,
uh,
Freddie Roach afterwards was saying that,
you know,
I was telling him to knock him out and he didn't say this in so many words,
but I heard this from somebody else,
took third person Paca kind of likes Cota and didn't want to knock them out.
You could see he clearly had figured his number out.
He could figure it.
He,
if he got his whole game and he didn't put him,
he didn't put them away.
He was just hitting him.
But he,
he actually liked him and knew he could really hurt him but didn't unreal.
Yeah.
And before that fight,
I was with some people who were friends with them,
like,
like Jeremy Piven who was doing a documentary about his life.
He looked over,
you never see a fighter do this.
He looked up,
I went,
how are you?
And it was doing and like,
like he was like,
like had walked into a club.
He was that relaxed.
Wow.
And then just went in there and I remember watching when as soon as code,
I think realized that that patio had figured his game out.
Like his,
his whole Jig was up and he all he had was just covering you just jab and
covering and that must be pretty frustrating.
Fuck yeah.
When you see why all of a sudden just get lit up.
Like you remember when Pacquiao fought,
um,
Oscar de la Hoya and you could see like somewhere in like the second round,
Oscar de la Hoya had this look in his face.
Like,
what the fuck just happened?
Like I can't even hit this dude.
Like this is,
this dude is just levels above me and I just got to go into a shell here and
survive,
you know,
fights a little bit like Duran did a little bit.
Yeah,
a little bit.
But you know,
he's,
he's really a style of his own,
you know,
his,
his leg movement is like,
its ability to leap in and leap out,
you know,
how fast he is and how mobile he is and how hard he hits too.
He's a bad little motherfucker.
It's really hard.
It's almost as hard as monogamy.
But anyway.
What?
Hey,
what's up?
Fuck you talking about.
So you have a two and a half year old.
I have a two and a half year old.
Still haven't got our kids together.
This is ridiculous.
I know.
We've got to do a two year olds.
They're almost exactly the same age.
We're both so similar in the fact that we're always so fucking busy.
We never get anything done that we're supposed to be doing.
Yeah,
I know.
We're going to do that though,
man.
It's always so much fun.
You're like one of my best friends that I never signed now.
It's terrible.
So how far does the same vadis you still live in Venice?
Yeah.
You got to thinking about moving out though.
Yeah,
you got to get out the gang land.
I told him the episode of Gangland this month.
Is it?
No,
I'm sure it has been.
They have fucking Tampa is on ganglion,
they find in Tampa.
There's a lot of gangs everywhere,
man.
Well that's a dumb show,
boy.
Gangland no,
it's scary.
It makes you think that there's gangs everywhere and everyone's shooting
everybody.
I like the first 48 you ever watch that show?
That's my new favorite show that I love that show.
Those shows were all educated criminals.
Now they know what not to do.
Yeah.
But you know,
a lot of a lot of crime though is,
is passionate and you're not thinking and you leave a trail and with technology,
the other thing is about that survivor guy.
Do you know the guy who's one of the producers of survivor and his wife,
uh,
turned up missing in Mexico and then they found her in a sewer and he's back
over in America and they're trying to figure out where they're going to charge
him and deport them to Stucco and what's going to happen really kill this wife
fucking arguing,
screaming and yelling.
The people heard screaming and yelling and then all of a sudden she disappears.
Fuck.
How scary is that?
People that are involved in relationships that are dirt,
they hate each other so much.
They just resort to killing each other in a marriage.
Like you got to know while you're killing someone.
I'm like,
oh my God,
my life is over.
I'm fucking killing it.
I gotta be honest with you.
I've had girls bring me to that level.
You have.
I'm not saying,
I'm not saying it's good.
I've gotten out of that,
but I have,
I have been in some awful just,
I've been outside of myself watching myself just behave like a huge,
a whole are both similar in that we
have,
we both taken chances on a lot of really crazy chicks just cause it was fun.
You know?
We are fun.
By the way.
When we first came to Hollywood,
we both did the exact same thing because we used to talk about it all the time.
Who would date someone that was just like fucking completely insane,
but it was like,
Eh,
no big deal.
It's fun that Phil Hartman Shit cleared all that out for me for sure.
When Phil Hartman got murdered by his wife,
I was like,
okay,
no more.
That's okay.
I just figured this out.
I thought it was fun.
This is not fun.
This is,
this is crazy.
What you bring into your life,
man.
And you see dudes do it all the time.
It makes things more exciting and it's a good distraction too,
you know,
cause especially in the stress of Hollywood and the stress of,
trying to make it,
it's like there's sometimes the stress is overwhelming.
You just want to get lost in something else.
So you want to have in a lot of sex.
Are you saying you call it in a crazy relationship?
A nanny.
But you know,
Dove Davidoff says if love was a drug,
people would be like,
dude,
stay away from that stuff.
You could lose your house.
Know that's fine.
It's the wrong kind of love.
It's true.
It is.
It's totally true.
Well it's,
it's not even just a love mean call it love,
but really it's the weird connection that people have to each other where they
need each other.
You,
you become connected.
Like,
ew,
ew.
There's a bridge between you and this person and you literally need them in your
life.
You know,
you can shake yourself of it,
but it's very hard getting out of a relationship.
I mean that twice.
How many dudes,
you know,
have you seen that their,
their girl breaks up with them and then starts dating someone else that they
know and they literally go insane.
Yeah,
it's insane.
It's like someone stealing happiness from you right in front of your eyes,
but you can't ever accept the fact that this is just a human being that doesn't
like you anymore and likes this other human beings.
It also comes down to a lot of people I believe,
get into relationships just so they can control someone else with their emotions
and with their,
you know that that's the other thing.
A lot of it really is what you learned from watching your parents.
If your parents are fucked up and a lot of people's ours,
it takes a lot to,
a lot of people's parents are really fucked up.
Right?
It takes a lot to overcome that early program.
And I think a lot of,
I don't know what you think about this,
but I was thinking about,
I think a lot of making a relationship work is just not,
first of all,
having very low expectations and then also coming to the equation and staying in
the equation as,
as a very,
as a very independent person.
Yeah.
You have to be independent and you also have to grow together and you also have
to be really honest with each other and you also have to find one.
There's not nuts and you have to not be nuts to,
in order to find one who's not nuts,
you have to not be nuts as well.
Absolutely.
You know,
to find a nice person,
you've gotta be nice,
you gotta be worthy of a nice person.
I had the best advice someone ever gave him to make a relationship work groups.
Well,
he said he had been married for 25 years ago.
What's your secret?
He goes,
dude,
I,
I know we,
we learn how to fight.
We learned that there are boundaries in places you don't go and we learn how,
like when we were frustrated or angry with each ever get shitty with each other
and insult each other.
Don't get violent,
don't throw things,
don't break my stuff.
Don't fucking,
don't call work and be a continent.
Don't get nutty.
Don't let your fear with things.
There's a way to fight and if you learn how to release the tension or whatever,
you'll you can make it work for a long time.
Are you listening to my son?
Yes.
This is what's weird is I was in a relationship that was so bad at one
point that I had to start recording her,
you know,
as evidence and I'm like,
I remember thinking going on semesters,
I was thinking like this is,
this is so bad that I am recording people for evidence.
I need to get out of this relationship.
And do you have those times?
Yeah.
Can we do something with those well out named?
It did.
Perhaps depending.
Yeah,
maybe.
Maybe we'd be about names.
We could beat it up.
Yeah.
Let's just change the sound of the voice.
Just a we just a wee bit because I've heard about these.
I think those would be interesting.
I actually public it would take me a while to find them,
but yeah,
I'd love that.
Mel Gibson,
one dat boy.
Woo.
There's another example we were talking about actors being fucking crazy and
thinking that you know that they're much more important and interesting than
they are because they're successful and he might,
people kiss their ass.
Yes.
Genuinely be sick.
I think so too.
I think that's insanity.
Well he's an alcoholic and you know doctor drew was talking about him and he was
saying that it seems like he's probably relapsed.
Like if you listened to the way he's talking and he's like,
and he has some sort of a mental issue,
a bipolar issue or something,
but,
but you know how much maybe that came from being an actor.
Maybe they came from people kissing your ass on the set.
You start believing it.
I did it when the part of rational part of your brain just stops working.
Just like a guy who takes roids in his bowl shrink.
I also think the acting when you're on a set all day,
it gets so boring cause real acting on a movie is waiting around all day.
Like I did this movie with Nick naulty and in Pittsburgh and Nick's been,
uh,
you know,
just the mixed martial arts and he's been doing,
this is the one where you play me.
Yeah,
I play you.
Oh yeah.
Oh by the way,
by the way,
as a movie coming,
I'm in co coming out called warrior that just tested through the roof for lions
gate.
It's got Tom Hardy and nick naulty and,
and,
and uh,
this guy,
this Australian actor,
Joel Edgerton and some really great actors.
But anyway,
it's going to be a great movie.
But,
um,
I,
I played Joe Rogan I to prepare for the role.
I literally watched a about Phi 50 hours of you,
and I'm not kidding on UFC.
Remember I called you about it.
I said,
you know,
and you said,
just take your time out of the equation as a,
as an announcer.
Anyway,
I watched you and watched you and I've gotten some rave reviews from my
performance late.
Thank you to my friend Joe Rogan.
I literally played too.
I was like,
how would Joe do this?
And then I just was,
you give us an example like where you real technical IRS agent.
I used words like wow.
And that there,
that's a huge move.
Cute.
You know,
just that like joke,
it's,
you don't really get huge.
Whether it's words and by the way he loves the game.
And I,
I'll tell you,
and I've had other people say this who really know sport.
If you are as good as it gets at what you do when it comes to calling us fights,
you're so knowledgeable,
you're so passionate about it.
And,
and I don't know of anybody who can call a file.
Thanks man.
It,
but it's,
you know what,
honestly,
it's um,
I'm just a professional fan.
It's easy because,
uh,
because of standup,
cause San San up is so difficult and you get really good at communicating and
you get really good at understanding,
you know,
economy of words and you know,
how to set things up and you know,
and,
and really self aware of how your sound and your,
you're,
I have so much harder that doing,
doing commentaries like weight easy.
But you know,
who else is great as Goldie gold is great,
he's fun.
The poetry he uses.
Like he's a poet man,
he's a poet.
He's so impressive.
Well he's very smooth,
you know,
and people like give him a hard time about saying stupid shit,
which you don't understand is how much of that he's just whinging.
You know,
he's winging a big chunk of the stuff that he's saying.
You know?
And sometimes when you wing Shit,
it doesn't always come out right.
And then you're,
you know,
you're stuck in a bad spot and you've got to kind of correct yourself a little
bit or you know,
and we goof on each other every now and then.
If we say stupid things,
you know,
but what he does is very hard to replace.
You know,
I tried doing his job once and I was terrible at it.
Now he's,
he's a very specific skill.
It is.
It's a very specific skill,
but you know,
you're,
you're the best there is at it.
So it's,
it's pretty fun to watch you while you spent like two months in Pittsburgh doing
that and you know,
I think it's going to be worth it at the end of the day.
It's a great movie.
So when does it come out?
Well,
they were going to release it September,
but it tested so high that I think lion's gate wants to push it toward the
Oscars,
if from what I'm told.
So,
uh,
maybe,
maybe December or something changed or you feel like it's that good?
Did you like it?
I haven't seen it yet.
I just saw clips.
But I liked the movies that you're in.
Are you one of those dudes that even though you're washing,
hanging over once,
um,
and I,
I'm almost never,
nobody believes me,
but I never watched what I do.
I'd love to.
I'm too critical of myself.
Hate those guys though,
that if they do something all of a sudden it's awesome and they love it.
Like you can't admit like Bob,
your show sucks.
Yeah.
It goes back to being,
um,
not honest with yourself and not having perspective.
I mean,
uh,
you know,
the,
I,
I don't watch what I do because I'm already critical enough and um,
you know,
it's,
for me it's not even about the movie that comes out as they experience.
It's fun.
Sometimes you have a really good time having a laugh on a set and doing and
acting or making believe that's fun for me.
I don't do it.
You know,
I do it because it's fun.
I think where I feel artistic is when I'm with stand up,
where I'm writing my own stuff and I'm kind of expressing myself.
That's a,
a different,
there's a different motivation for it.
So,
you know,
fuck you out.
That's the most fun thing for sure.
The way you know,
you know,
the thing about standards is you can never lie to yourself because you get up on
stage.
They either laugh where they don't and it's pretty brutal if it starts going
south,
man,
and you're in the middle of nowhere and somebody can't be faking.
What's funny that you think you have to really be connected to it in order to be
good.
And it,
let me ask you this about standing up not to turn us into a stand up thing.
But one of the other thing is,
um,
I thought about this,
somebody asked me some advice.
I go,
well,
I'll just write with your what you think is funny,
but in a way,
if you're trying,
if you're trying to be funny as opposed to I'm just expressing yourself honestly
in a way that makes you laugh.
Um,
when you're trying,
the audience kind of feels,
you manipulating them,
they feel the lie and it's never as funny.
Do you know what I mean by that?
It might work a little.
Yeah,
it does.
If you've been doing it for,
did you so long to see comedian,
the church comedian?
Yes,
I did.
You,
so then you saw orange Adams performing.
Yes,
I did.
And that's the kind of comedy I'm talking about.
That's the kind of,
it does work.
It's possible.
I don't believe it.
Well,
you know,
and,
and when people don't believe it,
it's that key word.
But there's like that,
that sort of style is like a style,
you know,
there's a style that will work in a crowd but will not work one on one.
Like Joey Diaz can tell you something one on one and it's just as fucking funny
as if he stand in front of 300 people saying it.
But there's a lot of comedy that's like,
so to them and premise and you know,
enunciation.
But it's a song I can hear the punchline could,
it's not funny as opposed to honest expression.
Let's let me still work.
Yeah,
it'll still work.
But then that's the difference between a hack and a real comic in my opinion.
Not to be too much of a purist that way,
but yeah,
we,
right.
Someone who's like on stage and they're getting angry at something that they,
they're not really,
why do I get two receipts?
What is this kills when they go crazy?
Like go you really mad.
It's a piece of paper you put in your pocket and you leave because somebody
said,
I walked in and I heard a guy like that and I want to do that.
I walked in,
I went,
oh,
I can't,
I can't stay here.
Yeah.
And my buddy Ken says,
you can't be that judgemental.
And I go,
dude,
I know that song.
I can hear two bars of that song and I know exactly where it's going.
I've been doing it too long,
you know?
And it makes you feel unfunny.
The thing is when you watch someone who saw uninspiring,
it takes all the energy out of me.
Exactly.
I worked with this guy and I what my opener couldn't make it like in the last
minute.
And so I work with this local guy and this local guy,
not only did he suck,
he went on for 45 minutes and he did a bunch of my shit.
No.
Yeah,
he did like reworked bits that were like from my old cds and he did this before
he brought me up and I don't know if he was doing it to be a dick and step on my
material if he doesn't know,
I don't even do those anymore.
That was like years and years old or if he was trying to fuck with my head or if
he's so retarded that he just,
this is what he does,
just steal shit everywhere and he forgets where it came from.
Wow.
I went on after him and I had to like jolt myself to be funny.
Like I had to listen to it because I wanted to know what the fuck he was saying.
Once I heard some of my material,
I'm like,
Ugh,
now I have to listen to this guy because I don't want,
I mean,
what if he does something that I do do right.
I don't want to repeat it,
you know,
so I have to listen this fuck now.
So I'm listening to this guy and it's like shocking all the inspiration out of
my brain and nothing he says he believes everything he says is just angry and
stupid.
And somebody said,
uh,
they said,
how do you know?
This woman asked me,
how do you know gene Hackman's a great actor?
What's your criteria?
And she goes,
because I always believe him.
You know,
it's the same kind of thing.
Yeah.
Same thing with the comic that you go,
Oh,
I always believe you like Daniel Day Lewis.
You don't have to go into it.
Do you believe them or not?
You know?
Yeah.
I mean,
and you know yourself when stuff,
when,
when stuff connects and stuff is real and there's a process in developing
material where there's a lot of times your go down a path and there's nothing
there for you that you thought there was.
You're fucking around with it.
But for whatever reason it doesn't come out and that,
that is a part of the process.
But there's a big difference between that,
which is just like someone trying to find the comedy and someone forcing it.
Someone like,
I've written plenty of things where I know it like the people would laugh.
Like I'll come up with that like a thing and it's like a trick and you go,
oh that's a trick.
I can't do it though because it's not me.
Like,
like that's a,
that's a trick on the audience that's just there to be funny.
It's like a surprise,
like a magic trick.
Like oh here's the list doing that.
I don't want to be that gun in that.
That sort of takes you out of who you are when you're on stage cause then you're
aware of that and when you're aware of that then it takes away from the muse,
whatever that weird connection is where you feel like you're a passenger.
Exactly.
You have sex with Kirstie Alley,
right?
Whoa.
I did not fuck.
Might have stepped up,
but at the hell Brian,
I didn't show.
This is great.
I didn't know I'd be saying,
is this the whole point of this fuck.
I'd be an ambush man.
It's all a trick.
Oh,
can I plug that?
I'm going to be a,
where you at?
I'm going to be at the Irvine Improv tomorrow.
Uh,
headlining eight o'clock.
Irvine Improv.
Oh,
the Irvine Improv is the shit I just did a whole weekend there.
That place is awesome.
I love it.
Irvine is awesome.
That's another good place.
You might have a little go family man show.
Did you see the Nick Diaz response to last week's podcast?
Yeah,
he was upset at me.
Him.
Wow.
Good.
Well do you know what Nick Diaz,
he's saying also that may him,
uh,
is too big then he wants to,
why does it make him come down to one 71?
Are you picking on me?
I'm,
you know,
I'm smaller than you,
which is true,
you know,
made him can never make one 70.
I mean he made it a long time ago when he fought GSP,
but he had to starve himself and get down there.
You know,
think ds is a natural one.
70 what?
What is your call if a,
I don't want to put you on the spot,
but if GSP fought Anderson Silva,
well if you gained weight the correct way,
you know,
um,
it would be very,
very interesting because will they do,
Anderson is definitely the best wrestler that the or or GSP rather is definitely
the best wrestler.
That Anderson is fun,
but physically he's a smaller man.
Anderson is really tall.
He's tall.
He's like,
I think he's six three,
six two or six three and he's really long,
man.
He's really long with his limbs.
That's one of the reasons why he can go up to two oh five and then down to 85 I
don't think he could make one 70 though.
He's thought about it.
He might be able to,
but it might be my too much of a strain on them.
But at one 85 man,
he's hard to fuck with he so fast.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
And if he's standing in front of GSP and GSP,
you know,
can't take them down or if he decided to trade with them and gets caught and
Anderson catches you.
He's so fucking accurate.
But he will.
He's got a big test and Chael Sonnen because Chael Sonnen,
the fight that he's having on August 7th that is the biggest guy at one 85
that's a wrestler.
Chelsea big motherfuckers.
He really,
when you saw him manhandled Nate Marquardt.
Anybody that can do that today.
Nate Marquardt is no jokes and beast.
Nate Marquardt.
It's a fucking beast.
You know handled last wrestler,
I think Greco Roman guy.
Yeah,
he's a beast too and he has his double his power double.
He runs through guys.
It's like impossible to stop almost but,
but up if he tries to,
if he tries to trade with a,
he's got it.
Yeah.
He's going to be fucked.
If he,
everybody who tries to trade with Anderson gets fucked.
He's too accurate.
He's too slick.
He has in an athletic ability.
That's very rare.
He's has this ability to move in and out
so fast.
If you look at the Damien Maia fight,
like how quickly he can like launch an attack and move forward and spring acts
you and tag you.
Th the need that he hit my with was,
he was like no wind up.
He just leaped through the air and smashed him with a fucking flying knee.
There's very few humans that could,
he looks like he's got springs in his body.
The way he handled Forrest Griffin,
nobody's ever been able to do that to Forrest.
Forrest Griffin is huge,
huge,
huge and good punter kicker too.
Yeah,
he's a real solid to 30 before he cuts down at two oh five.
He's a giant light heavyweight and Anderson just ate him up.
He's just,
he's a freak,
but they would like can to stop the shot.
That would be the thing.
And the other guy like that is um,
a fedora.
I'd love to see him fight Brock.
I just see that we're doing,
I know I got caught in that and nothing to take away from for doing,
but I mean he kind of,
that,
that's something that anybody can get caught in.
But as far as like just timing and being able to connect and counter.
I mean,
he's just ridiculous.
I would like to see him fight life.
He's a,
I think he's definitely a special athlete,
but he's also a small heavyweight,
you know,
it's two 30 or something and he showed up big hole in his game with the
overdoing fight.
He said he just got over confident,
which I,
I could see.
I mean,
why wouldn't you get over confident?
You haven't lost and Tyler's,
everyone's fucking terrified of you,
but he just,
you know,
you fucked up and we're doomed.
Garden for two.
It was just too nasty off of his back.
I would like to see him fight again though.
He's got to fight Alistair Overeem,
which is an even bigger tests really,
I think.
Yeah.
What about Brock?
I don't ever have,
it's probably not going to happen.
You know why talking to happen?
Because the m one guys that control him,
unless they all get hit by a meteor,
it's like he's there just wanting too much.
You know,
the,
the arguments pay him that much.
Well,
you know,
first of all they're all involved in some sort of a lawsuit right now that I
can't talk about,
but it's not,
the data wouldn't pay him.
It's that there's a thing called code promotion and that's what these guys want.
They want to be able to cope,
promote UFC events and that's what they were offering.
They wanted to give you fade or,
and they wanted all the other Russian guys that they handle to to fight in the
UFC as well.
So we would take on a bunch of guys that we didn't necessarily want and then on
top of it they would cope,
promote.
So it'd be UFC with m one or m one global presents UFC or whatever the fuck.
However they would set it up.
They would literally like share 50% of the revenue,
which is like the UFC was like what the fuck are you talking to them about 50
but still be cool like in a marvel girl cap Conner.
I know it's not marvel versus Capcom because m one global is it's,
they don't have enough to bring to the table.
All they have is one fighter.
UFC.
It's not like even dream.
If it was a copra motion between UFC and dream,
well at least in dream you got Aoki,
you got,
you know,
a,
a lot of like high level guys over there.
It's not quite as like high level is the UFC.
But a lot of really good guys,
they already all residents over there.
Dana White's genius has been,
he's kept the UFC,
the superstar and no one fighter.
You know,
he's so good at that.
Yeah,
they've made a bunch of guys famous stars,
but there's so many of them.
Whereas with boxing,
the unfortunate thing about boxing is there's really only interest on a few
weight divisions.
You know,
there's an interest,
whatever pack outs fighting whenever Lord Floyd Mayweather is fighting whatever
the Klitschkos are fighting.
And even the Klitschkos not so much.
You know,
there's,
when was the last big time paper view super fight with the Klitschkos?
I can't remember.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's never been anything that's helped us in any way.
Cause I never thought they were,
you know?
Yeah.
Well there he's really good.
Vladimir is very good technical boxer,
but the deal is that people don't really care enough.
There's not passion.
Like when Tyson was fighting or when Lennox Lewis is fighting even or Riddick
poll was fighting,
there's passion.
Uh,
Holyfield title fight was a big deal as well.
It's like there was passion to those guys and personality.
Yeah.
I mean it's not that Vladimir is not a fucking awesome boxer.
It's just for whatever reason people aren't passionate about watching him.
You know,
this is not that mean.
I mean people love Hopkins mean he's a throwback.
He said also finer.
Both that guy,
you know,
but you know,
like there's no,
he's 44 I think and,
and took at least see what he did to Kelly Pavlik.
Oh Dude,
he's just,
boxing is unbelievable.
We should get past Hopkins who you got,
you know,
you've got Pacquiao,
you've got,
you know,
Roy Jones Jr when he's still finding at least people are interesting.
But Roy Jones Jr once he lost the steps,
we've got another guy who,
you know,
once he lost that speed,
that crazy blinding speed.
Isn't that crazy to watch?
It's this thing about Hopkins is Hopkins was always very tight away in the
middle of our pod.
You know,
we're probably going to stop.
Let's stop right now.
It's five minutes before we're going to stop because Brian has to ping and I to
be stopped with boxing talk.
But,
uh,
that's not the best thing for comedy podcasts,
but I don't think this is a comedy podcast anymore.
It's just interesting shit.
fleshlight.com or go to Joe's website and click on the fleshlight link and you
can get yourself 15% off.
It feels better than your hand flashlight,
flashlight,
flashlight.
This a Saturday night.
I'm at the House of Blues and San Diego.
One show,
10:00 PM with Joey Coco Diaz Cock suckers.
I'm coming down planes,
trains and automobiles.
Get ready,
bitches and a then Sunday is the UFC on versus so he'll be there for that too as
well.
Um,
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
Thank you very much for tuning in.
We always appreciate it as always,
and um,
see you dirty bitches next week.
Thank you for nature.
Bye.